je souhaite la bienvenue dans notre
hémicycle au premier ministre et aux
membres du nouveau gouvernement
[Applaudissements]
la parole la parole est à vingt minutes
du bi muller monsieur le premier
ministre puisqu'il me revient de vous
adresser la toute première question
d'actualité je vous exprime au nom de
mon groupe
nos félicitations républicaines pour
votre entrée en fonction je regrette
votre choix politique mais je souhaite
avant tout la réussite de la france et
donc le succès de votre gouvernement
en revanche j'ai beaucoup de mal à
imaginer comment vous allez pouvoir en
même temps mener votre politique est
resté fidèle à vos convictions
vous vous dites gaulliste social mais ne
nous y trompons pas votre gouvernement
penchera bien plus à gauche que vous
malgré vos tentatives furent réussis de
recrutement à droite c'est bien un
programme de gauche que vous allez
devoir appliquer monsieur le premier
ministre pourtant les français n'en
peuvent plus ils attendent un changement
de politique pas un recyclage de
ministre avec quelques têtes d'affiché
d'ailleurs les trois quarts de vos
ministres étaient déjà membres du
précédent gouvernement incapable de
réformer durablement le pays et ils ont
accentué les fractures économique
sociale et territoriale
comment avez vous pu vous féliciter dès
votre prise de fonction que la france
est l'un des taux de croissance les plus
élevés d'europe en 2019 alors qu'elle
était 24e sur 28
comment pouvez-vous vous inscrire dans
une politique migratoire laxiste ayant
fait entrer l'année dernière un record
de 276000 nouveaux immigrés légaux soit
49 % de plus que sous nicolas sarkozy
comment conduire une vraie réforme des
retraites et mettre en place une mesure
d'âge indispensable pour préserver les
pensions des français quand plusieurs de
vos ministres
ils sont ouvertement défavorable alors
répondez nous en vérité comme nouveau
capitaine du gouvernement avez vous le
courage de reconnaître que le cap
n'était pas le bon et qu'il est urgent
d'en changer je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
sic
s'il vous plaît seul le premier ministre
à la parole vous l'écoutez merci merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
je voudrais d'abord vous dire toute
l'émotion et tout l'honneur que je
ressens m'exprimant aujourd'hui pour la
première fois devant vous en ma qualité
de premier ministre devant la
représentation nationale
sachez sachez que j'ai et que j'aurai
toujours un grand respect pour le
parlement et pour l'assemblée nationale
et pour l'assemblée nationale et que je
m'emploierai toujours vis-à-vis de vous
comme vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de la
nation a incarné les valeurs de respect
et de dialogue
madame la députée jusque là tout va bien
madame la députée madame la députée il
n'aura échappé à personne et en
particulier et en particulier avoue même
que ce nouveau gouvernement entre en
fonctions dans un contexte très
particulier une crise une crise
sanitaire d'une ampleur exceptionnelle
qui vous le savez n'est pas terminée une
crise économique et sociale qui a déjà
commencé et qui s'annonce comme étant
sans doute la plus difficile que la
france l'europe et le monde auront
affronté depuis la crise de 1929 avec
madame la députée les valeurs qui sont
les miennes
avec les valeurs qui sont les miennes
j'ai l'honneur j'ai l'honneur de diriger
ce gouvernement qui sera un gouvernement
de combat qui sera un gouvernement
tourné vers l'efficacité qui sera un
gouvernement de dialogue qui sera un
gouvernement des territoires
parce que parce que cela ne répond pas
simplement à une conviction dans le
cadre des orientations dégagées par le
président de la république parce que
surtout ce sera un gage d'efficacité
pour lutter contre la crise nous devront
être unis nous allons engager un plan de
relance ambitieux nous allons engager un
plan de relance ambitieux qui sera à la
fois marqué par la nécessité de faire
face au drame humain au drame humain que
vont rencontrer des personnes et des
territoires et qui sera d'autant plus
efficients que dans la continuité de la
logique de transformation qui irriguent
ce quinquennat
nous investirons dans l'avenir la
transition écologique les territoires la
solidarité nationale
le gouvernement aujourd'hui constitué
est tout au service de ses ambitions
et je m'emploierai personnellement à
veiller aux résultats et à l'efficacité
de notre action au service de la france
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
calmez-vous la parole à madame la
présidente valérie rabault et elle seule
merci le seul président monsieur le
premier ministre le président de la
république vous a confié je le cite la
responsabilité de tracer un nouveau
chemin pour notre pays
pensez vous que ce nouveau chemin soit
compatible avec le maintien de la
réforme des retraites
en clair monsieur le premier ministre
maintiendrez vous oui ou non une réforme
à laquelle 61 % des français sont
opposés
une réforme injuste qui divisent les
français fragilise un très grand nombre
d'entre eux au moment monsieur le
premier ministre où la france doit faire
pâques pour se relancer
je vous remercie la parole à monsieur le
premier ministre
le seul président à madame la présidente
je viens de le dire à l'instant
la crise est clair le nouveau chemin
qu'a annoncé le président de la
république nous devons impérativement
tenir compte de ce nouveau contexte pour
l'ensemble des champs de l'action
gouvernementale au premier rang desquels
la réforme des retraites que vous venez
d'évoquer je voudrais préciser devant la
représentation nationale
la façon dont mon gouvernement va
aborder ce sujet dans les semaines et
les mois à venir
dès cette semaine je recevrai l'ensemble
des partenaires sociaux qui seront avant
le 20 juillet réunit de façon collective
dans une conférence de méthode
mon objectif est de mettre tous les
sujets sur la table
je commence par vous dire que la santé
je souhaite régler en large par le sujet
dans le cadre du ségur cette semaine
avec des négociations conduites sous
l'égide du ministre de la santé et dans
lesquels je suis intervenu dès hier pour
demander à ce que l'effort considérable
est méritée et justifier que la nation
doit faire pour les soignants en terme
de salaire soit complétée et vous le
savez en vos qualités d'élu de terrain
par des créations d'emplois dans les
établissements de santé la santé les
retraites la dépendance l'assurance
chômage
le plan de relance tout sera mis sur la
table
nous allons écouter et concertée
seule cette méthode sera efficace madame
la députée nous nous retrouverons avec
les partenaires sociaux pour décider à
la rentrée ce qui relève de la
négociation et de la concertation
s'agissant des retraites j'y viens oui
mais mesdames et messieurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés
vous le savez vous le savez aucun sujet
si important soit-il ne peut être
traitée efficacement
s'il n'est pas éclairé d'une cohérence
d'ensemble de l'action gouvernementale
pour les retraites et j'en termine
madame la députée il a d'ores et déjà
était acquitté que nous distingue riom
les concertations à reprendre sur la
réforme de forme à laquelle nous ne
renoncerons pas sur un système de
retraites plus juste plus juste
qu'attendent de leurs voeux tous les
français en revanche nous le sépareront
nous le sépare au rang des dispositions
qu'il y a lieu de prendre pour
sauvegarder le système actuel et
convenez toutes et tous avec moi que la
situation financière de ce système n'est
pas tout à fait la même
depuis qu'il subit lui aussi de plein
fouet l'impact de la crise économique
qui pourrait surtout les bancs de cette
assemblée
indépendamment de ce que vous pensez du
futur régime laisser s'effondrer le
système de retraite actuel
nous devons donc en responsabilité et
avec les partenaires sociaux et dans un
cadre concerté prendre les dispositions
nécessaires pour assurer la sauvegarde
merci madame la présidente vous avez la
parole
seul premier ministre après pêche
l'inspirent de remarque d'abord tous les
partenaires sociaux y compris ceux qui
étaient favorables à la réforme des
retraites sont contre le maintien de
cette réforme dans le contexte actuel
tous vous êtes tout seul
monsieur le premier ministre contre les
partenaires sociaux au delà au delà
au delà cette réforme maintenir cette
réforme relève de l'irresponsabilité
monsieur le premier ministre
plutôt que relancer un débat sur les
retraites fait le plan de relance ça
fait 15 jours que l'assemblée est bloqué
sur le plan de relance que vous avez
annoncé
d'après les estimations que nous avons
la france est le pays l'union européenne
qui subit qui subit la détérioriation de
son pib le plus importante colmater
cette chute nécessite deux choses
monsieur le premier ministre
soutenir le pouvoir d'achat les
allemands l'ont fait ils ont donné 300
euros par enfant dans votre gouvernement
il n'y a eu aucun soutien pour la
demande des ménages
nous vous avons proposé nous vous avons
proposé ici 250 euros par famille plus
100 euros
vous avez dit non
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre il faut un plan de
relance économique qui traite les trois
urgences écologiques sociales et
économiques
vous avez refusé la prime climaque nous
vous avons proposé
c'est elle qui peut faire de la relance
il suffit madame la présidente
la parole à monsieur stanislas guérini
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
permettez moi tout d'abord au nom de la
république en marche de vous féliciter
ainsi que votre gouvernement nommé vous
n'ignorez rien des difficultés de
l'ampleur de la crise que nous avons
affronté mais je suis certain que vous
serez faire face avec le sens de l'état
et de l'intérêt général
permettez moi également de rendre
hommage à l'action du gouvernement
sortant
conduite par votre prédécesseur edouard
philippe et à travers eux l'action qui a
été menée par cette majorité pendant
trois ans pour mettre en oeuvre les
réformes voulues par le président de la
république
mais aujourd'hui monsieur le premier
ministre je veux parler d'avenir de
l'avenir de notre pays c'est à dire de
sa jeunesse
cette jeunesse qui a montré sa capacité
à se mobiliser pendant la crise
sanitaire pour aider pour être utile
notamment aux personnes âgées celles que
l'on regarde parfois avec inquiétude
quand elle manifeste sa colère
alors qu'elle demande avant tout qu'on
lui offre un avenir un avenir où elle
n'est pas à payer toutes nos dettes
financières mais aussi écologique un
avenir où l'égalité salariale entre les
femmes et les hommes ne soient pas
simplement un principe un avenir avec
des perspectives de formation et
d'emploi
la république en marche a formulé de
nombreuses propositions pour que dès la
rentrée 2020 aucun jeune ne soit laissée
sans solution que tous puissent disposer
d'une activité n'a revenu d'un
accompagnement bref que la génération de
comiques 19 ne soit pas une génération
sacrifiée
vous avez nommé un gouvernement de
combat vous l'avez rappelé alors battons
nous aussi pour donner un avenir à nos
enfants ils doivent être au coeur du
nouveau pacte social que nous avons à
écrire au coeur de la promesse
républicaines de liberté d'égalité et de
fraternité au coeur de notre projet
alors monsieur le premier ministre
pouvez vous dès à présent nous dira si
la jeunesse constituera une priorité du
plan de relance que vous êtes en train
de préparer
je vous remercie
merci monsieur de député la balle est à
monsieur le premier ministre
et je vous serais reconnaissant d'éviter
les bavardages qui crée un brouhaha qui
rend difficile d'écouter les questions
et encore moins les réponses
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président ai-je besoin de
rappeler à la représentation nationale
et qu' il y a huit millions de jeunes en
france 12 % de la population c'est à
dire et c'est une chance une force l'un
des taux les plus élevés d'europe
deuxième élément de données chiffrées
dans les semaines et mois à venir à la
rentrée
entre 700 et 800 mille jeunes vont se
présenter comme on dit sur le marché du
travail et en même temps par l'effet de
la crise par l'effet de la crise c'est à
peu près le nombre d'emplois que
celle-ci 700000 a déjà détruit cette
considération nous fixent ensemble
la première obligation qui sera au coeur
du plan de relance à savoir apporter à
notre jeunesse
dans ce contexte fortement dégradé des
réponses en termes de formation de
qualification et d'emploi je rappelle
que le précédent gouvernement et la
majorité ont déjà beaucoup agi en la
matière
l'obligation de formation jusqu'à 18 ans
va entrer en vigueur le 1er septembre
prochain
il y a la garantie jeunes il y a le plan
d'investissement des compétences et
notamment sa dimension pour les plus
jeunes il y a
l'augmentation très forte des entrées en
apprentissage d'ores et déjà réalisée
grâce à l'action conduite par muriel
pénicaud
il y a plus récemment l'aide
exceptionnelle destinée à un million
deux cent mille jeunes dans la crise du
code vite et bien les dispositions du
plan de relance que nous préparons
équivaut qui vous seront soumises
prochainement iront plus fort et plus
loin dans le registre de la formation et
de l'entrée dans l'emploi des jeunes
la deuxième la deuxième préoccupation
qui est la nôtre concerne la transition
écologique vous le savez parfaitement
mesdames et messieurs les députés
c'est un sujet qui à bon droit nous
passionne à toutes et à tous mais
davantage encore les plus jeunes
nous devons être ambitieux madame la
ministre vous le serez en la matière est
associée là aussi dans les territoires
le maximum de jeunes pour leur donner
l'occasion concrètement concrètement de
favoriser la transition écologique de
notre pays et les ambitions que nous
portons enfin mon gouvernement dans la
continuité du précédent entend accroître
l'ensemble des dispositifs de lutte
contre les discriminations et de relance
de l'ascenseur social troisième
préoccupation majeure de la jeunesse de
notre pays
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole et up
s'il vous plaît je vois là on écoute
maintenant monsieur alain brunel qui
seul à la parole
merci monsieur le président le groupe de
télécommunications nokia a annoncé son
intention de supprimer 1230 trois
emplois en france soit un tiers de ses
effectifs
c'est le quatrième plan social depuis le
rachat d'acs at-elle du sang par nokia
en 2016 alors que nokia a perçu 280
millions d'euros de crédit impôt
recherche
c'est la recherche et le développement
qui est sacrifiée par le groupe au
risque de voir disparaître le dernier
constructeur d'équipements télécoms en
france à l'heure où l'on parle de
reconquête de notre souveraineté
industrielle
l'état ne peut rester l'armé au pied
devant ce nouveau plan de casse de
l'emploi à l'heure où air france prévoit
de supprimer 7000 600 emplois que sanofi
annonce la suppression d'un millier de
postes en france que qu'un plan social
menace 5000 emplois chez airbus que
renault annonce de 4600 suppressions
d'emplois l'état doit prendre ses
responsabilités
il est indispensable de maintenir de
transformer et de développer nous outils
industriels afin de préparer l'avenir
les entreprises dont nous parlons ont
reçu des milliards d'euros d' aides
publiques
le gouvernement ne saurait accepter que
les salariés de ces entreprises
stratégiques soit sacrifié la relance
économique ne peut se faire sur le dos
des salariés et pour le seul profit de
la poignée d'ultra riches auquel le
gouvernement fait toujours les yeux de
chimène le monde d'après exige de
changer de braquet
la question du groupe communiste et stap
monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous me garantir qu'il n'y aura
aucune casse sociale et qu'aucun salarié
ne restera sur le carreau
qu'elle garde fous allez-vous mettre en
place merci chers collègues la parole à
madame agnès pannier relâché ministre
chargé de l'industrie
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député bruyneel vous parlez
de la politique industrielle et vous
savez que ce gouvernement a été
particulièrement en pointe sur la
politique industrielle depuis trois ans
vous savez que ce gouvernement est celui
qui le succès d' que ce gouvernement a
fait en sorte et que cette majorité de
recréer de l'emploi industriel sur les
territoires donc non non nous sommes
nous en action pour effectivement faire
en sorte de limiter la casse sociale à
un moment inédit de crise mondiale sur
l'activité économique et l'activité
industrielle en particulier cette
politique industrielle elle va être au
coeur de notre relance monsieur brunel
au coeur de notre relancer ça d'ailleurs
été le premier déplacement du premier
ministre dans une entreprise
industrielle
vous mentionnez un certain nombre de
dossiers et vous avez bien raison
ces dossiers nous les suivons de près
parlons de sanofi sanofi c'est un plan
d'évolution des effectifs
il n'y aura aucun départ contraint je
veux vous rassurer
et moi je veux saluer aussi
l'investissement de 600 millions d'euros
de sanofi dans une usine à vaccin à
marcy l'étoile qui vient d'être annoncée
en juin et je peux vous dire que j'ai
obtenu de la part des dirigeants de
sanofi qu'il maintienne à moyen terme
l'emploi sur la france voir qu il le
développe donc oui nous sommes à la
manoeuvre
vous parlez de nokia et je partage
totalement votre préoccupation et
d'ailleurs je sais que des députés sont
aujourd'hui mobilisés aux côtés des
salariés de nokia entre montparnasse et
invalides
maintenant le député bothorel la députée
rixin pour ne citer que ces deux là
le président de région monsieur loïg
chesnais-girard et nous sommes à la
manoeuvre pour trouver des solutions car
il ne s'agit pas d'invectivés il s'agit
de trouver des solutions il s'agit de
bâtir une industrie qui soit compétitive
et qui recrée l'emploi en fera la
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
président olivier beige merci beaucoup
monsieur le président permettez moi
d'abord de féliciter monsieur le premier
ministre et l'ensemble de son
gouvernement pour leur domination et
leur souhaiter bon courage au nom des
députés agir ensemble dans leur mission
ma question monsieur le premier ministre
concerne le service ferroviaire pendant
la crise du coc vie de la sncf a
considérablement ralenti ses cadences
qui était parfaitement compréhensible
lorsque nous étions confinés
aujourd'hui le service a repris mais pas
dans son intégralité c'est encore un
service adapté qui parfois est inférieur
de 30% au service normal sur certaines
lignes
cela pose trois problèmes un premier
pour les françaises et les français qui
galère au quotidien pour se rendre à
leur travail
un second problème au moment de la
relance économique pour faire en sorte
que tous les territoires y compris ceux
qui sont concernés par le tourisme
puisse être desservis et enfin une
troisième difficulté en termes
d'aménagement du territoire et je sais
monsieur le premier ministre que vous
êtes extrêmement sensible à cette
question d' équilibre des territoires
pour l'attractivité et la compétitivité
ça pose d'ailleurs une question en
termes de développement durable puisque
si nous souhaitons supprimer les
liaisons aériennes plus courte il faut
encore que tous les territoires puissent
être relié à part le faire rapidement
aux grandes métropoles mais également
aux aéroports internationaux cas je rêve
bien entendu que la sncf redevienne ce
grand fleuron national qu'elle est elle
était autrefois je rêve même un jour
qu'elle puisse atteindre le niveau de
performance et de ponctualité à la
japonaise
mais dans l'immédiat il faut déjà
récupéré le service que nous avions
avant la crise du que vides
pouvez vous monsieur le mini et le
premier ministre
intervenir auprès du directeur de la
sncf afin que nos concitoyens puissent
retrouver rapidement un service de train
normal merci ma parole est un monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur le
président président olivier becht
mesdames et messieurs les députés
merci de cette question le la reprise de
l'activité du transport ferroviaire que
j'ai tout particulièrement suivis
pendant les semaines précédentes dans le
cadre de la mission que m'avait confié
le précédent gouvernement sur le dé
confinement est marqué par la volonté de
faire redémarrer notre économie dont les
transports sont leurs des vecteurs de
faire redémarrer la vie quotidienne de
la nation tout en assurant les
protections sanitaires dus aux voyageurs
c'est ce que nous avons fait je rappelle
à chacune et à chacun que pendant la
période du confinement
vous l'avez dit monsieur le député cette
activité a été particulièrement réduite
mais depuis la mi juin environ
l'offre de tgv et de trains intercités
est redevenu proche de la normale même
les trains de nuit ont recommencé à
circuler la semaine dernière il n'en
reste pas moins il n'en reste pas moins
que le taux de réservation en
particulier des tgv est encore proche de
50% ce qui a conduit la sncf à adapter
son offre
ne doutez pas de notre volonté
incarnée par monsieur le ministre des
transports de voir revenir
l'activité du service public ferroviaire
dans les toutes prochaines semaines et
si possible dans les tout prochains
jours à la normale j'en profite pour
vous rappeler combien le transport
ferroviaire constitue une priorité de
cette majorité
nous avons nous avons ensemble et avec
les région autorité organisatrice
considérer que la priorité était à la
régénération du réseau partout sur le
territoire
en dégageant à ce sujet des efforts
inédits et bien entendu dans le cadre de
la transition écologique
nous allons poursuivre et amplifier ces
efforts je vaux m
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à monsieur antoine
savinien je vous remercie monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la justice de
longue date je me félicite de partager
la même vision que vous de notre système
judiciaire est sans aller jusqu'à
qualifier de barbouzes les magistrats du
parquet je dois admettre qu'il ya
matière à réflexion mais ici sachez que
nous sommes très seul l'oralité
judiciaire n'a plus lieu d'exister en
modernise en informatisant automatise
bref on déshumanise la justice les
défenseurs des cours criminelles sont
légion et nous sommes peu nombreux à
nous être élevés contre cette terrible
expérimentation donc monsieur le
ministre
bienvenue dans l'opposition vos
déclarations passées ne peuvent que
réchauffer nos coeurs tant il est vrai
que depuis deux ans et demi nous nous
sentons seuls dans l'appréhension de ce
que devrait être notre justice
mais avant pourriez vous nous éclairer
vous ne deviez jamais occupé ce fauteuil
et vous êtes là vous ne deviez jamais
avalé de couleuvres et vous avez retiré
votre plainte pour cette atteinte
inadmissible à votre vie privée et au
secret professionnel
alors monsieur le ministre vos actions
futures seront elles en adéquation avec
vos déclarations passées ou pas merci la
parole est un monsieur eric
dupond-moretti garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice
vous avez la parole un peu de silence
s'il vous plaît
dans vous avez raison on n'est pas au
spectacle et je vais répondre à la
question que me posent monsieur le le
député d'abord vous savez tous que quand
on est avocat pénaliste libre on n'a pas
la même parole que quand on représente
l'état ça n'échappe à personne
avez vous toujours dit la même chose
c'est vrai qu'à un moment j'ai dit que
je n'accepterais pas cette tâche doit y
avoir une dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'années on va mettre un terme définitif
non le jeu vous en prie le sait déjà
c'est déjà compliqué pour moi c'est là
c'est une première mais
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît laissez moi
monsieur le député j'ai un sens aigu du
contradictoire et du respect de la
parole de l'autre j'aimerais que vous me
laissiez au moins exprimer
on pardonne et moi on ne juge on ne les
messieurs le député je voudrais vous
répondre complètement
on ne juge pas des hommes sur des a
priori me semble-t-il
vous me jugerez sur ce que j'ai fait
quand je l'aurais fait et pardonnez moi
pardonnez moi vous je vais vous dire
quelque chose quand on est haut quand on
est au café du commerce on ne s'exprime
pas alors comme quand on est avocat
quand on est avocat on ne s'exprime pas
comme quand on est ministre ça c'est
pour la forme
moi au 15 mai au café du commerce je ne
porte pas de cravate à l'assemblée jean
mais une voie là alors je vais vous
répondre
je je je vais vous rép
et est ce qu on décompte les
interruptions des banques aba voilà on
souffre en silence mais ce serait bien
que cela fait trois fois ma parole a été
celle d'un homme libre ma parole sera
celle du ministre de ce gouvernement
je remercie je tiens à vous le dire tout
choses très très vite
le président de la république et
monsieur le premier ministre la
confiance qu'ils m'accordent je veux
travailler avec vous tous députés
députés de la majorité comme député de
l'opposition
encore un mot monsieur je sais qu'il est
possible parce que l'idée que l'on se
fait de la justice
continuez
[Applaudissements]
l'idée l'idée monsieur le député que
l'on se fait de la justice vous me
l'accorderez transcende les clivages
j'ai vécu la commission d' enquête
parlementaire d'outreau
à ma gauche il y avait si vous me
permettez ce mauvais jeu de mots le
député marceau monsieur houillon
monsieur vallini sensibilités politiques
différentes
82 propositions on peut tous travailler
ensemble
voilà m'arrive jamais
monsieur le député merci monsieur les
troupes l'air l'écoutent monsieur merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre
j'avoue que je reste un peu sur ma faim
mais j'entends votre appel et le fait
que nous puissions tous travailler
ensemble
j'espère que vous n'oublierez pas non
plus la gelée juridiction civile
commerciale prud'homale administrative
le rôle du conseil d'état aussi dans nos
institutions
au jour d'aujourd'hui parce que tout
cela est particulièrement important
et comme vous l'avez dit à juste titre
vous voyez l'exercice change il n'est
pas si simple
ici les mots ne sont plus rien les
français ont besoin d'action ils
jugeront vos actes et je vous souhaite
bon courage et d'être très bon merci
chers collègues la parole à madame
nathalie et l'image merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
c'est dans l'adn du modem depuis
toujours de défendre la famille et cela
fait maintenant trois ans que notre
groupe milite sans relâche en faveur
d'une politique familiale ambitieuse
moderne et efficace
c'est pourquoi nous regrettons de ne pas
la voir dans l'architecturé du nouveau
gouvernement
et ce d'autant que la crise sanitaire a
mis les faits mis à rude épreuve elles
sont réapparus pour ce qu'elles sont une
valeur refuge
berceau des solidarités et pilier de
notre cohésion sociale les inégalités de
notre système ont également été mises en
exergue et nous devons maintenant le
redonner justice lisibilité simplicité
de manière pérenne au delà des mesures
d'urgence porté par le gouvernement
pendant la crise la mission
d'information sur l'adaptation de la
politique familiale française aux défis
du 21e siècle dont je suis rapporteur a
rendu ses conclusions la semaine
dernière et j'aurai l'honneur de vous
remettre prochainement ce rapport il est
largement soutenue sur tous les bancs
mais également dans les territoires par
les français et par les associations
familiales
ils portent 40 propositions fortes
visant au premier chef à mieux protéger
les familles alors redonner du pouvoir
d'achat est alors offrir toutes les
conditions d'un plein épanouissement
nous devons assumer une véritable
politique nataliste enjeux
démographiques fondamental pour la
société française de demain en
particulier face au défi de la
dépendance
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la croisée des
chemins alors qu'une politique familiale
renforcer constituerait un puissant
outil économique
un statu quo ne ferait que rajouter de
la crise à la crise alors monsieur le
premier ministre
question simple quelle place pour la
famille lien quelle politique familiale
comptez vous mener pour qu'elle ne soit
plus les grandes oubliées de ce
quinquennat je vous remercie
la parole à monsieur olivier viron
ministre des solidarités de la santé
[Applaudissements]
madame madame la députée nathalie à
l'image je vous remercie pour votre
question importante qui met en exergue
l'importance de la politique familiale
dans un pays comme la france
je salue la qualité de vos travaux nous
avons eu l'occasion de débattre ensemble
est tombé d'ailleurs souvent d'accord
lorsque j'étais parlementaire à vos
côtés dans le cadre des exercices
budgétaires et il ya eu des missions
conjointes d'ailleurs qui ont associé
des députés et des oppositions je salue
aussi notamment le député du rpt ton
pour la constance de son travail sur la
politique familiale et le député
guillaume schiste avaient également sur
un autre banc cette assemblée émis des
recommandations doc bref la question la
famille elle transcende également la
caisse les clivages politiques
la politique familiale pays ce sont 50
milliards d'euros par an 50 milliards
d'euros par an de prestations qui sont
versés à plus de 6,6 millions de
familles les familles nous les avons
soutenu madame la députée limaces en
particulier au coeur de la crise virale
avec une aide 450 millions d'euros qui
ont été apportées pour faire vivre les
structures d'accueil de jeunes enfants
la politique familiale
ça va bien au delà des crédits c'est
l'éducation des enfants c'est les 1000
jours le premier de huit jours qui a été
initiée par adrien taquet c'est
l'accueil le soutien aux familles
parental
les modifications des schémas des
familles dans notre pays je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont 23 % des familles
qui sont monoparentales les a unis du
21ème siècle ne sont plus les mêmes
modèles de famille que celle du 20è
siècle il ya également la question de
l'homoparentalité qui est à prendre en
compte
et puis toutes les prestations qui
doivent être versés pour permettre de
briser ces inégalités sociales à la
racine
lorsque l'enfant est tout petit le
soutien aux parents le soutien à
l'éducation
beaucoup de mesures transcende
d'ailleurs le simple champ la politique
familiale madame la députée quand on
dédouble les classes les effectifs dans
l'est dans les zones d'éducation
prioritaire on mène aussi une politique
familiale efficace bref je vous rejoins
sur l'importance vitale de soutenir la
parentalité de soutenir les familles
dans notre pays quelles que soient les
façons d'ailleurs de le faire vous avez
devant vous le ministre en charge de ces
questions j'en suis très heureux très
fier et je me réjouis de pouvoir
travailler avec vous dans les mois à
venir
merci monsieur vu ni madame le député
merci monsieur le ministre
en tout cas je vous invite à lire le
rapport qui comprend de nombreuses
mesures la politique familiale forte
depuis a été forte dans notre pays
pendant sa plus de 60 ans et ella ella
portait elle a porté ses fruits
elle a subi des coups de rabot on en
voit aujourd'hui les conséquences en
tout cas nous serons toujours aux côtés
du gouvernement s'il entend la
promouvoir
et sinon nous continuerons à nous battre
alors si ça me le député la parole est à
monsieur jean hugues ratenon
si monsieur le président monsieur
monsieur le premier ministre c'est on
sait que réaliste puisque ne pouvant
vous interprétez outils de votre
politique générale à venir
je souhaite alors vous entende en votre
qualité d'aix monsieur déconfinement
concernant les outre-mer qui n'est pas
une souffrance mais bien la france dès
le début du col vide associations
syndicats collectifs de citoyens et ong
ont alerté le gouvernement sur les
spécificités des territoires d'outre-mer
les défaillances structurelles la
pauvreté et la précarité dans ces
territoires ont été ignorés et
aujourd'hui ce sont les populations qui
en paie le prix le prix fort en guyane à
mayotte depuis le mois d'avril la
situation sanitaire est devenu de plus
en plus inquiétante
l'épidémie flambent le nombre de malades
le nombre de morts augmente
qu'avez vous fait pour éviter cela pire
vous regarder ailleurs et autoriser les
vols commerciaux entre mayotte et la
réunion sans réel plan de protection des
habitants en martinique ce sont les
médecins cubains qui débarque en renfort
à la place de l'état français pour les
remercie
mais où sont nos médecins français en
guadeloupe c'est la double peine
en plus du coc vide elle fait face un
facteur très aggravant le manque d'eau
potable
un style d'un département français en
2020 devant nos territoires abandonnés
le 1er avril le député européen younous
omarjee a dû solliciter l'aide de
l'union européenne
à la réunion c'est l'explosion des colis
alimentaires
conséquence d'une économie fragile et de
la provôté qui s'aggrave
notamment chez les personnes âgées où
est la dignité aujourd'hui cerise sur le
gâteau vous n'avez trouvé aucune femme
aucun homme d'outre-mer digne à vous
j'ai occupé la fonction de ministre
est ce la veut d'abandon des outre-mer
ou alors allez vous apporter de vraies
réponses aux problèmes posés
merci je relève la parole est à monsieur
sébastien le corps du ministre d
outre-mer merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député ratenon je vous le dis comme
je le pense je ne pense pas que vous
rendez service aux territoires
d'outre-mer
en remontant les collectivités
territoriales les habitants de ces
territoires contre l'état l'état a
répondu présent dans cette crise du
mieux qu'il a pu
la communauté des soignants c'est l'état
les policiers c'est l'état les gendarmes
c'est l'état des pompiers c'est l'état
donc
rendez-leur aux marges remercier les est
considéré que sous l'autorité du premier
ministre du gouvernement d'edouard
philippe précédemment de jean castex
aujourd'hui la mobilisation a été totale
je vais vous dire monsieur le député
vous n'êtes pas votre première
contrevérité près je vous disais il ya
deux jours vous preniez à témoins
l'ensemble des maires de la réunion pour
leur expliquer que cette majorité
parlementaire diminuer le concours du
gouvernement de l'état pardon aux
collectivités territoriales la dgf elle
est stable depuis 2010 est mieux que
cela
elle augmente dès cette année pour
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales d'outre-mer
vous êtes conseiller municipal de bras
panon la dgf augmentent de 4% cette
année
donc si on veut y arriver pour les
territoires d'outre-mer consacrons-nous
aux vraies difficultés et arrêtons de
colporter des contre vérités
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame emily shay as
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
transition écologique
avant toute chose je souhaiterais vous
féliciter et vous apporter tout mon
soutien tout notre soutien à votre
nomination au poste de ministre de la
transition écologique
madame la ministre
lundi 29 juin dernier le président
recevait à l'elysée les membres de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat et
s'engage et à transmettre au
gouvernement et au parlement 146
propositions je tiens ici à saluer à mon
tour le travail de ces 150 citoyens en
matière d'écologie
nous devons aller plus vite plus fort
plus loin deux chemins se dessine dans
le paysage politique français
celui de l'écologie dogmatique de
l'extrême gauche punitive décroissante
qui laisse au bord du chemin les
questions de l'emploi et des solidarités
et il ya celui que je choisis une
écologie progressiste positive inclusive
enthousiasmante et pragmatique qui
pensent que l'utilité de la 5g mérite
d'être explorée sans postures
démagogiques sortir de la communication
dire la vérité aux français
être lucide et ambitieux les
propositions de la convention citoyenne
riche et audacieuse dépendent pour
nombre d'entre elles des collectivités
territoriales comme la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments la limitation
des constructions dans la nature le
développement des circuits courts
l'engagement des mobilités moins
polluantes la protection de l'écosystème
ou encore la participation citoyenne
tout ne passe pas tous ne passent plus
par l'état nous le savons les élus
locaux sont un maillon essentiel de la
transition écologique qui doit se faire
en grande partie au niveau des
territoires
dans son allocution du dimanche 10 10 14
juin par dont le président de la
république annoncé vouloir ouvrir une
nouvelle page des relations entre détail
les territoires en donnant des libertés
et des responsabilités inédite aux élus
locaux
madame la ministre comment le
gouvernement compte-t-il articulé en
même temps la mise en place des mesures
fortes en matière environnementale à
l'échelle locale et de nouvelles
missions pour nos mères
j dans le territoire merci on a bien
débuté la parole et à madame barbara
pour pili ministre de la transition et
que merci merci merci monsieur le
président merci chers collègues je vais
encore avoir du mal à passer de l'autre
côté merci chers collègues et minutieuse
dont je connais l'investissement sur le
territoire grenoblois et dont j'attends
beaucoup de soutien
tout d'abord un petit mot pour vous dire
que je me sens quand même un petit peu
ému d'être là dans notre maison commune
que j'aime tant que j'aime tant et où je
sais que je compte beaucoup d'amis et de
soutien je remercie beaucoup
monsieur le président de la république
et monsieur le premier ministre pour
leur confiance dans cette tâche que je
sais lourde que je sais est immense et
où je sais je peux je suis très attendu
et que je suis très attendue par tout le
monde
je mesure complètement l'immensité de la
tâche je mesure la tente
je mesure les énormes obstacles mais je
mesure aussi l'immense volonté que j'ai
de faire bouger les choses et faire
bouger les choses
faire bouger les choses je n'y arriverai
pas tout seul et je sais et je sais
parce que j'en ai eu l'assurance et j'en
remercie premier ministre je sais que je
vais pouvoir compter sur l'ensemble du
gouvernement
je sais que je vais pouvoir compter sur
une équipe sur une équipe qui sera là
pour me soutenir et qui sera là pour
avancer avec moi dans le plan de relance
pour avancer avec moi dans l'application
des mesures proposées par la convention
citoyenne pour le climat je vais avoir
avec moi évidemment elisabeth borne à
qui je succède et que je remercie
tellement pour son travail
je vais avoir avec moi bruno le maire
pour la relance économique
je vais avoir avec moi julien de
normandie sur l'agriculture je vais
avoir avec moi évidemment au sein du
ministère emmanuelle wargon et jean
baptiste djebbari sur le logement sur le
transport sur les outre mer évidemment
je vais avoir sébastien lecornu sur la
mère annick girardin
bref je viens voir du monde et je vais
vous à marc simoneau
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît un peu de silence la
parole est à monsieur julien dive
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à julien de normandie
que je souhaite aussi féliciter pour sa
nomination communiste de l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation monsieur le
ministre
pouvez vous nous confirmer que c'est
bien l'ingénieur agronome qui fixera la
doctrine de la politique agricole
nationale et non le dogmatisme rampant
qui a tort a nourri jusqu'à aujourd'hui
la grille bashing et qui figure déjà sur
ses bancs pour vous amener à répondre je
vous propose de vous engager sur un
sujet d'actualité sur lequel le
président de la république a lui-même
voulu prendre date l'interdiction du
glyphosate en france ce sujet épineux
provoque un doublé mois dans notre
société
d'un côté l'aspiration des consommateurs
par rapport à l'utilisation de cet
herbicide qui n'est pas appliquée
contrairement aux idées reçues sur des
cultures alimentaires en place et de
l'autre la crainte et les inquiétudes
des agriculteurs français face à
l'absence d'alternative durable et
respectueuse de l'environnement ainsi
que de moyens financiers je rappelle que
contrairement à beaucoup de leurs
homologues en europe et dans le monde
nos paysans respectent des règles et des
normes environnementales et sanitaires
bien plus exigeante
pour l'instant ce débat n'a réussi
qu'une seule chose
dresser les consommateurs contre les
agriculteurs une annonce étant toujours
plus simple quand elle n'est pas
expliqué j'ai donc des questions claires
en espérant des réponses tout aussi
clair monsieur ministre afin que tout le
monde sache aujourd'hui ce qu'il en est
quelle est la date de l'interdiction du
glyphosate en france nos agriculteurs
ont besoin de visibilité et le temps
semble compté proposez-vous des
dérogations
si oui allez voulait fonder sur un type
de culture en situation d'impasse
ou alors sur une conduite culturale
quelle alternative mettez vous sur la
table pour eux et avec quels
financements rendre accessible une
alimentation saine et de qualité pour
tous
c'est aussi rappelé l'effort fourni par
les filières si vous mettez des règles
supplémentaires pour nos agriculteurs
mettez aussi les moyens pour les
accompagner c'est à vous de trouver les
alternatives qui tiennent compte de leur
réalité
il en va de notre sécurité alimentaire
d'autres puissances agricoles merci
chers collègues la parole à monsieur
julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député julien dive
ce sera l'ingénieur agronome qui va vous
répondre
jamais de dogmatisme et je crois que
cela est partagée par beaucoup
vous savez pendant la période qu'on a
vécu les français ont pu compter sur
l'agriculture ont pu compter sur les
agriculteurs sur les éleveurs sur les
pêcheurs cette deuxième ligne et je
crois que nous devons beaucoup à notre
agriculture
nous leur devons beaucoup parce qu'ils
ont connu nous leur devons beaucoup
parce que c'est une part de notre
identité nous leur devons beaucoup parce
que c'est un formidable secteurs
d'activité économique et nous leur
devons beaucoup également dans
l'accompagnement face aux défis aux
défis techniques technologiques et aux
défis écologiques comme la transition
avec les produits phytosanitaires alors
s'agissant de votre question je vais
être très clair la première question
c'est sûr l'objectif de sortie du
glyphosate
le président de la république a été très
clair là dessus il a fixé des objectifs
temporels en disant que ses objectifs
temporels devait s'appliquer aux regards
également des produits de substitution
parce que l'accompagnement de nos
agriculteurs
il est absolument indispensable le
deuxième c'est que nous le ferons avec
méthode et je peux vous dire que cette
méthode
à mes yeux elle est absolument essentiel
cette mobilisation d'accompagnement deux
ministères du ministère de l'écologie
des agences de l'ensemble des acteurs et
des parlementaires qui sont énormément
mobilisés sur la question et puis le
troisième élément et je m'engage dessus
c'est la transparence et cette
transparence je sais monsieur le député
que vous appelez de vos voeux
on a par exemple avec la majorité
présidentielle demandé un recensement
près d'un tiers
on rendra lé résultat public très
prochainement
près d'un tiers des exploitations sont
déjà sortis du glyphosate
otri un autre tiers sont en train de
sortir du glyphosate et tous ces
résultats nous les rendrons public pour
montrer l'évolution y compris sur les
achats objectifs maintenus mer séparant
les messages à ça laly la parole et à
monsieur boris vallot monsieur le
premier ministre il ya entre le
gaullisme social et le maquereau nisme
total une différence de nature de morale
et de méthodes et vous avez indiquée
depuis votre prise de fonction vouloir
laisser une place plus importante au
dialogue social il vous recevez dans
quelques heures les partenaires sociaux
vous avez l'occasion de les entendre
la cfdt la cgt force ouvrière la cftc la
cftc cgc la fsu l'unsa ont indiqué avec
netteté le medef aussi qu'il fallait
retirer la réforme des retraites qui
n'était pas tant de remettre de la
tension et que notre énergie devait être
consacrée à l'emploi a sauvé nos
entreprises face à la multiplication des
plans sociaux et qu'il aurait t-il
répondu que vous leur été réglé à court
terme cette affaire de retraite en est
que le président parle d'un allongement
de la durée de cotisation que doit-on
comprendre monsieur le premier ministre
la cfdt la cgt force ouvrière la cftc
cfe cgc l'unsa la fsu ont indiqué ont
indiqué qu' il était temps de retirer la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qui avait
fait déjà beaucoup de dégâts et qui en
ferait encore beaucoup aussi
l'obstination déraisonnable du
gouvernement devait l'emporter sur la
raison sociale
nous devons consacrer notre énergie à
l'emploi à la jeunesse à l'insertion à
la pauvreté et que leur est-il en même
temps répondu eh bien que les français
auraient une préférence pour le chômage
au moment où tant d'entre eux sauf
menacés dans leur emploi il faut confier
aux partenaires sociaux le soin de
négocier une réforme de l'assurance
chômage avec des principes conformes à
notre temps monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez dit ne pas croire au consensus
nous ne croyons pas aux 10 ans us dur
monsieur le premier ministre vous nous
dire que vous avez entendu les
partenaires sociaux tous les partenaires
sociaux et que vous allez retirer la
réforme de l'assurance chômage et la
réforme de retraites et vous mettre au
travail pour le plan de relance
la parole est à madame elisabeth bornes
ministre du travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
boris vallot je voudrais tout d'abord
vous remercier pour votre question qui
me donne l'occasion d'exprimer devant la
représentation nationale
ma reconnaissance au président de la
république et au premier ministre pour
la confiance qu'ils m'accordent alors
oui je suis fière et heureuse de
rejoindre le ministère du travail de
l'emploi et de l'insertion un ministère
du dialogue alors vos questions portent
sur la réforme des retraites et de
l'assurance chômage
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont exprimé leur
volonté de faire vivre la démocratie
sociale avec l'ensemble des partenaires
sociaux
notre pays traverse une crise sans
précédent
précédent et ça ça n'est pas depuis
trois ans monsieur le député nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens veulent une
protection sociale à la hauteur des
enjeux du 21e siècle notre
responsabilité est donc d'ouvrir le
dialogue sur l'ensemble des sujets parce
que vous parlez de des retraites
monsieur le député est ce que notre
système de retraite est juste
non non et vous le savez il est injuste
pour les femmes dont les pensions sont
inférieures de 40% à celle des hommes
il est injuste pour nos concitoyens les
plus fragiles
il n'est plus adapté à la réalité des
parcours professionnels
est ce que notre système d'assurance
chômage a permis de ramener les chômeurs
vers l'emploi
non et vous le savez
voilà pourquoi nous devons en
responsabilité engager une concertation
pour plus de justice sociale avec
l'ensemble des acteurs
je serai donc aux côtés du premier
ministre pour engager ce dialogue dès
demain chômeurs et si la parole est un
monsieur stéphane mazars
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le ministre mes premiers mots
seront pour vous féliciter
suite à votre nomination aux fonctions
de garde des sceaux et permettez moi au
nom du groupe la république en marche de
vous adresser tous nos voeux de réussite
à la tête de ce grand ministère régalien
permettez moi permettez moi aussi de
saluer votre prédécesseur
madame nicole belloubet qui a été une
grande ministre de la justice
celle ci au cours des trois dernières
années a porté des textes importants
dans cet hémicycle et elle a toujours
fait preuve vis-à-vis des députés de
tous les bancs d'un profond respect
monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous connaissez la justice à travers de
la noble mission qui est celle de la
défense mais c'est désormais dans toutes
ses dimensions que vous allez devoir
l'appréhender de la cour d'assises du
tribunal paritaire des baux ruraux en
passant par le conseil de prud'hommes le
tribunal de commerce le tribunal
judiciaire ou encore le point d'accès au
droit de la profession d'avocat et des
autres professions réglementées hauts
fonctionnaires ou agents de l'état qui
soit magistrats greffiers surveillants
pénitentiaires ou encore agent de
probation ainsi monsieur le ministre ce
sont de très nombreux lieux d'exercice
du droit et d'innombrables acteurs à son
service qui sont désormais sous votre
responsabilité ou sur votre autorité et
ceci vous le savez attendent parfois des
moyens supplémentaires parfois de
nouvelles réformes parfois simplement
une reconnaissance pour leur permettre
de poursuivre l'exercice de leur mission
exigeante est essentiel dans un état de
droit
monsieur le ministre lors de votre
passion de pouvoir hier à la
chancellerie vous avez d'ores et déjà
énuméré quelques grands chantiers que
vous souhaitez ouvrir remise a pas de
l'ordonnancé 58
l' ordonnance de 45 travail sur la
présomption d'innocence et secret de l
enquête le parquet européenne monsieur
le ministre
avec un tel programme quelles seront vos
priorités et quel sera votre méthode
pour permettre à la justice d'être une
administration accords davantage à la
hauteur de cette vertu si attendu par le
concitoyen
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice monsieur
le président monsieur le député mazars
merci d'abord pour vos gentils moore je
voudrais dire à tous les parlementaires
que je mesure l'ampleur de la tâche et
que je n'embrasse avec beaucoup
d'humilité
cette tâche à venir je voudrais
également vous dire ma fierté d'être ici
devant la représentation nationale
mes priorités sont celles la réponse est
un peu dans la question pardonnez-moi
sont celles que j'ai évoquées hier nous
voulons une justice de proximité
ça a un sens il ya d'ores et déjà un
certain nombre de pistes je les ai
évoqué l' enquête préliminaire
sa durée la présomption d'innocence
les violations du secret de l'enquêté
ma méthode
monsieur le député puisque vous me posez
la question elle est très simple nous
avons connu vous et moi et parfois
ensemble d'ailleurs les mêmes enceinte
nous sommes des amoureux du
contradictoire moi j'ai besoin de vous
dans mes nouvelles fonctions
j'ai besoin de vous à la fois pour me
guider et aussi pour la contradiction
que vous nous apporterait rien n'est
plus important que le contradictoire
qu'il s'agisse d'une décision de justice
ou d'une décision ou d'une décision
politique
voilà ce que quelle sera ma méthode
auprès des magistrats de l'ensemble des
personnels de mon administration de tous
ceux qui voudront me rencontrer ma porte
est ouverte
vous n'aurez pas à la forcer
que ce soit les parlementaires de la
majorité comme ceux de l'opposition
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure dans l'
affaire d'outreau les politiques de
toutes sensibilités sont parvenus à
trouver un ensemble de décisions dans
mon nez dans ma mémoire 82 propositions
c'est donc qu'il est possible de faire
cela et c'est ce que je ferai merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur jean marie
sermier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
personne ne nie la réalité du
réchauffement climatique
il s'impose à nous pas demain
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs par exemple
le savent bien
les gelées de printemps du au démarrage
précoce de la végétation des épisodes de
canicules les périodes de sécheresse
abîme chaque année davantage les
récoltes en montagne on constate une
baisse de l'enneigement dans les forêts
ce sont les scolytes profitant de la
hausse des températures qui ravage les
massifs d'épicés à ces constats partagés
nous oblige tous nous oblige à refuser
les idéologies nous oblige à agir pour
l'environnement avec pragmatisme et avec
ambition dans le domaine par exemple de
l'énergie on a trop entendu de discours
anti nucléaire alors que le nucléaire
est une énergie décarbonée pilotable
soyons cohérents
défendons le maintien du parc existant
et investissons sur de nouvelles
générations de p r pour réduire notre
empreinte carbone dans le domaine du
logement
on a trop confondues politiques sociales
et politiques environnementales soyons
ambitieux investissons massivement dans
l'isolation de nos bâtiments dans le
domaine du transport
certains nouveaux maires veulent parquet
les voitures aux portes des grandes
villes le problème ça n'est pas la
voiture
le problème c'est la pollution engageons
un plan ambitieux de développement des
véhicules propres en particulier à
l'hydrogène développons le ferroviaire
réhabilitant les petites lignes mais
aussi le tunnel
on tuera développons le fluvial et
notamment le canal seine-nord europe
ces orientations devraient dépasser les
clivages climat politique
hélas ce ne sont pas celle tracée par
eux madame la ministre de la transition
écologique hier votre priorité est de
concrétiser les engagements de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
constitue trop souvent un catalogue de
taxes de normes et d'interdictions nous
ne voulons pas d'une écologie punitive
qui opposerait la planète à l'humain
celle qui au fond on veut la
décroissance
monsieur le premier ministre pensez vous
comme nous que la france doit concilier
la croissance et la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
la parole est à madame barbara pour
piler ministre de la transition
écologique
merci merci monsieur le président cher
jean marie sermier un plaisir de vous
retrouver toujours aussi en verve et
quelque part un peu triste de vous
quitter parce que nous avons fait un
beau travail ensemble au sein de la
commission du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire de
l'assemblée nationale nous avons eu des
des grands débats et vous en avez cité
certains mais sur tous ces sujets sur
tous ces sujets je continuerai à faire
comme je lé fais auparavant on va
travailler ensemble on va essayer de se
mettre autour de la table et on va
trouver les solutions ensemble avec vous
évidemment à l'assemblée nationale
et ça va arriver très vite avec les
citoyens de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat qui ne s'intéressaient pas ces
questions au départ et quand ils se sont
jetés dans ce sujet ils ont compris
l'enjeu et ils nous ont fait des bonnes
propositions avec les territoires en
lien avec jacqueline gourault évidemment
parce que on ne peut pas réussir la
transition écologique
si on ne la fait pas sur les territoires
dont convainc réunir évidemment l'airé
les élus locaux pour pouvoir travailler
sur la question des énergies vous savez
la feuille de route est claire et vous
pouvez compter sur moi pour faire en
sorte qu'elle soit appliquée parce qu'on
a un vrai sujet aujourd'hui monsieur le
député monsieur abad
on a un vrai sujet sur le fait que nous
votons des lois et qu'elle ne sont pas
appliquées et vous pouvez compter sur
moi pour faire appliquer les lois pour
faire appliquer les stratégies qui ont
été votées par notre représentation
nationale
j'y tiens énormément et je m'y
emploierai vous avez oublié dessus
j'ai de l'économie circulaire sur
laquelle je salue le travail de brune
poirson qui a vraiment fait un bon
boulot sur le sujet et que nous allons
également continuer voilà les enjeux
sont là la relance l'application de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat nos
travail sur les territoires du concret
c'est sûr ça qu'on va bosser
merci madame la ministre la parole
monsieur yannick favennec becker merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
de la culture cher roselyne bachelot que
je suis heureux de retrouver dans cet
hémicycle
vous le savez les artistes sont
indispensables au lien social à
l'ouverture et à l'épanouissement de
notre société
ils sont des acteurs majeurs du
développement et de l'attractivité des
territoires comme celui que nous avons
en partage madame la ministre
les pays de la loire une terre de
festivals la politique culturelle de
notre pays dans sa globalité doit faire
face à de grands chantiers mais mais
comme vous l'avez dit lundi l'urgence
absolue en ce début d'été sera notamment
d'aidé à la remise en route des
festivals
vous annoncez des états généraux des
festivals mais ils ne sont qu'une
solution à moyen terme
or aujourd'hui il y a urgence les
annulations de festivals sont
dramatiques tant pour les artistes les
compagnies que pour les très nombreux
bénévoles qui les portent ou les
territoires qui les soutiennent et les
accueille et j'ai une pensée toute
particulière pour les festivals annulés
dans mon département de la mayenne au
plan national 4000 manifestations ont
été annulées entre avril et août
le coût de ces annulations approcherait
les deux milliards 6,2 euros avec des
conséquences majeures en termes d'emploi
et d'économie des territoires la
création d'un fonds de 10 millions
d'euros annoncé par le ministère de la
culture pour faire face à ce séisme
n'est malheureusement pas à la hauteur
madame la ministre notre pays dans une
particulière vulnérabilité culturelle
des femmes des hommes des territoires
sont dans l attente d'une réponse
appropriée du gouvernement s'ils
n'attendent pas tout de l'état il on se
pose cependant besoin d'être soutenus ma
question est simple vous qui êtes là
ministre des artistes
et des territoires quelle réponse
d'urgence à la hauteur des enjeux
entendez vous apporter l écosystème du
spectacle vivant
en prenant en compte l'importance de nos
festivals
merci madame la ministre merci chers
collègues la parole à madame roselyne
bachelot ministre de la culture
monsieur monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés à
monsieur le député cheikh yannick
favenec bécaud vous avez rappelé notre
amour pour notre cher mayenne et qui a
été durement éprouvée par la suppression
d'un certain nombre de festivals je
pense au foin de la rue qui développe la
musique en ruralité
je pense aux 3 éléphants rien à voir
avec la politique un qui promeut des
musiques actuelles où je pense aussi aux
nuits de la mayenne qui développe le
théâtre classique et tous ces festivals
ont été soit annulés soit reporté le
gouvernement n'est pas resté inactif
dans ce domaine et je veux rappeler
l'action de franck riester qui est là
que je salue qu'avec détermination à
aider ce secteur qui a bénéficié bien
sûr et qui continue à bénéficier de
toutes les mesures générales
l'activité partielle et prêts garantis
par l'état le fonds de solidarité ainsi
que des mesures spécifiques
on peut penser au fonds d'urgence pour
le spectacle vivant dont ont bénéficié
les festivals au total ces cinq
milliards d'euros qui sont déjà
mobilisés bien entendu nous allons
continuer nous allons continuer à
travers le troisième projet de finance
de loi de finances rectificative et pour
le secteur culturel
c'est 1,06 milliard d'euros qui seront
mobilisés des dépenses fiscales des
exonérations sociales et bien sûr des
crédits budgétaires
et puis également dans cette loi de
finances rectificative
ce qui a été voulu par le président de
la république et qui sera très utile
pour nos festivals c'est à dire le
prolongement de cette année blanche pour
proroger les droits de l'intermittence
cc près d'un milliard d'euros ses 950
millions d'euros qui seront mobilisés
alors bien sûr vous avez 10
cette mesure d'urgence des 10 millions
d'euros qui seront utilisés pour nos
festivals c'est quand même des mesures
d'urgence et puis aussi d'adapter à la
crise sanitaire des festivals qui
pourraient reprendre
nous allons bien sûr continuer et ses
dispositions que vous attendez seront au
coeur du plan de relance le plan de
relance c'est la culture
la volonté du président de la république
merci la parole est à monsieur mots et
haï brotherson monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs du gouvernement
chaque collègue johann d'abord je crois
qu'on est on peut être de l'opposition
est souhaitée et malgré tout la
bienvenue et bon courage au nouveau
gouvernement
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre et outre-mer rien ne sera plus
jamais comme avant
on l'a entendu ce slogan au niveau local
comme au niveau national avant la crise
qu'ovide 15% des polynésiens était
considérée chômeurs soit seize mille
deux cents personnes auxquelles
l'honnêteté intellectuelle commandes
ajouté vingt-trois mille deux cents
individus que les statistiques ne classe
pas étrangement comme étant en recherche
d'emploi la réalité preco vide nos
places donc déjà au delà des 40 % de
sans emploi avec la fermeture des
frontières et l'arrêt des dessertes
aériennes régulières décision de l'état
mais aussi des principales sources de
touristes comme les états unis
ces 22 % du pib polynésiens qui est en
danger de disparaître d'ici la fin de
l'année ce sont quinze mille chômeurs de
plus qui sont attendus dont 11000 dans
le seul secteur du tourisme créatif de
l'état facteurs exogènes internationaux
limite du statut cette crise a également
rappelé de manière douloureuse d'une
réalité post coloniale qui s'applique à
tous les outre-mer la dépendance de nos
économie de comptoir et la perte de
notre souveraineté alimentaire 88 % de
ce qui est consommé en polynésie où
pourtant tout pousse est importé
allons-nous attendre le jour où des
cargos ne viendront plus accros aux une
nouvelle crise sanitaire politique ou
économique
pour nous saisir de cette réalité
monsieur le ministre la polynésie attend
au delà des ping pong statutaire de
savoir si l'état va assumer ses
responsabilité outre-mer
non pas pour retrouver la situation en t
mais pour construire ce fameux monde
après les solutions existent elles ont
pour nom permaculture apiculture circuit
qu à quoi pour ni jardin partagé baisse
responsable énergies propres et
renouvelables
certainement pas une énième version
bétonné tropicalisé du plan marshall
ma question est simple êtes vous prêt à
lancer avec les responsables locaux un
véritable plan de transformation d
outre-mer
faire plus de résilience et moins de
dépendance citant pierre rabhi appelant
colibri où chacun aura un rôle à jouer
merci je ferai de la parole est à
monsieur sébastien lecornu ministre les
autres mains merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député prg personne merci pour vos
félicitations républicaines dans ce que
vous avez indiquée il a semble-t-il
trois priorités qui déjà se se distingue
dans la continuité de l'action de la
ministre
girardin la première des choses est
singulièrement en polynésie française
c'est la stabilité institutionnelle lax
et à pays et les communes qu'il faut
saluer ici dans le rôle très
opérationnelle qui a été jouée sur ce
terrain et dans la gestion de la crise a
permis justement de réussir la période
de confinement les mesures de mise en
protection des populations et donc il
faut le dire en polynésie française
les choses ont été tenus grâce à cette
stabilité institutionnelle la deuxième
des choses ce sont les mesures d'urgence
pour la protection de l'emploi les
mesures sociales
je ne reste pas ici mais enfin on agit
sur le secteur bancaire on agit
évidemment sur des avances de trésorerie
pour le pays je sais que la députée
votre collègue député maina sage a
déposé des amendements en la matière
c'est l'accompagnement évidemment de
l'économie puis vous l'avez dit des deux
compagnies aériennes qui connaissent des
difficultés importantes sur le cas de
l'état va se mobiliser
la troisième des choses c'est évidemment
imaginer une relance qui tient compte
des spécificités des différents
territoires d'outre-mer est là où je
vous rejoins dans la tonalité de votre
question c'est que quelque chose décidé
depuis paris de manière autoritaire ou à
la vague ne pourra pas fonctionner donc
il faut qu'on soit capable de décliner
le plan de relance sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
de manière spécifique sur les différents
territoires d'outre-mer et dans la
prolongation ce qui a été dit par la
ministre pompili il est évident que la
question de la transition écologique
d'occuper une part fondamentale de cette
relance tant tel est d'ailleurs un des
éléments de l'identité de l'attractivité
touristique de la polynésie française il
ya un enjeu et olivier ferrand le sait
sur la santé sur lequel je sais que vous
nous attendait sur la signature d'une
convention santé avec le ministre la
sûreté des solidarités on va s'y
employer
et puis bien sûr traiter l'ensemble des
sujets
l'éloignement avec ses sujets
d'autosuffisance vous avez parlé de des
questions alimentaires mais pas que la
question de l'énergie me semble-t-il au
site une question importante notamment
d'un certain nombre d'atomes en tout cas
nous serons aux côtés des élus de la
polynésie française pour le faire
monsieur le député merci monsieur le
ministre la parole
sonia crimi président madame la ministre
délégué à l'industrie mes chers
collègues
la france est un pays de tradition un
pays de terroir un pays de savoir faire
est un pays de compétences depuis 40 ans
notre déficit commercial n'a cessé de se
creuser le poids de l'industrie dans le
pib ne cessé de décroître avec les
mesures engagées par la nouvelle
majorité nous pouvons noter une nette
amélioration depuis 2010 est visible par
une augmentation de la création
d'emplois industriels dans les
territoires et les chiffres le prouvent
le coc vide 19 a révélé des
problématiques d'approvisionnement et la
crise économique qui s'annonce risque
d'entraîner les déclins de nos champions
nationaux laissé entendre le rachat par
des puissances étrangères des biens et
des connaissances essentielles à notre
pays notre souveraineté économique est
essentielle à la survie de notre
démocratie
et cette politique ne peut se mener sans
coordination avec les administrations de
l'état
la défense la sécurité intérieure et les
centres de recherche ainsi que les
institutions internationales l'union
européenne l'om c'est le cd eux le fmi
et j'en passe cette coordination est
nécessaire afin d'accompagner le retour
de ces industries français sur le sol
français tout en veillant à ne pas
déséquilibrer les pays en voie de
développement comme l'a rappelé le
président de la république et le premier
ministre le gouvernement constitué
récemment est un gouvernement de combat
vous avez accompli des missions
essentielles madame la ministre avant et
pendant la crise ces missions sont
aujourd'hui d'autre nature puisqu'il
s'agit aujourd'hui de réarmer la france
économiquement dans les secteurs
essentiels à la survie de notre pays
et accompagner le souhait des français
afin de produire au plus près du
consommateur vous pouviez vous nous dire
quelques mots madame madame la ministre
sur cette nouvelle orientation merci
merci chaque collègue la parole à madame
agnès pannier rinsch ministre de
l'industrie merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée crimi merci de rappeler
d'abord le bon bilan de ce gouvernement
en matière industrielle a effectivement
nous vivons une ère différente
aujourd'hui mais ma conviction c'est que
le ministère de l'industrie
ça ne doit pas être le ministère des
problèmes mais le ministère des
solutions et notre stratégie
elle s'articule autour de quatre axes le
premier axe c'est que notre industrie
soit un pilier de notre puissance
économique
c'est tout l'enjeu de la politique de
relocalisation qui sera ni simple ni
rapide mais que nous avons d'ores et
déjà engagé et qui doit être pensée non
seulement en pays au niveau de la france
mais également au niveau de l'europe
et vous savez les engagements qu'a pris
la commission européenne et le mouvement
extraordinaire qu'a fait l'allemagne
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république et du ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la relance pour
soutenir l'industrie européenne
notre deuxième axe c'est d'apporter des
solutions à la décarbonation de nos
activités parce que l'industrie elle la
doit décarbonés ses propres processus
mais surtout c'est elle qui va permettre
de trouver la façon de décarbonés la
mobilité de décarbonés la construction
de logements et de tertiaire et donc
c'est tous ces leviers que nous devons
accompagner vous connaissez notre
investissement par exemple dans les
projets hydrogène que nous allons
poursuivre nous devons aller plus loin
plus fort plus vite en lien avec la
ministre des transitions écologique
le troisième axe c'est d'être plus agile
plus agile parce que nous devons faire
l'industrie du futur lusine du futur
c'est une transformation impérieuse si
nous voulons rester dans la course
industrielle enfin le quatrième axe etc
l'indus
elle doit être inclusive c'est un projet
de société vous connaissez mon
engagement pour les femmes
nous devons l'ouvrir pour les jeunes et
également pour ses eaux sans diplôme et
aux carrières qu'ils peuvent mener dans
l'industrie ou les rudes mine où la
parole est aux mains d'hommes vasile
deux ponots monsieur le premier ministre
quatre ministres de l'ecologie en trois
ans pour un bilan ridicule face à
l'enjeu de notre siècle
pas de ton envers ni sociale ni rien du
tout ce nouveau gouvernement ne veut
rien dire
macro un jour macron toujours voici
votre seul mot d'ordre voix qui a
accepté de ne rien dire de votre
politique générale avant que le monarque
de l'elysée d'anne parlé nous apprenons
qu'un commissaire au plan devrait être
nommé depuis que le temps que nous
insistons sur la nécessité de la
planification nous ne pouvons que nous
réjouir de cette victoire idéologique
mais pour planifier quoi pour planifier
la destruction du règne j'étais à
perpignan ce lundi pour défendre le
dernier train de primeurs de france
les cheminots ne décolère pas à sa
suppression est le symbole du fiasco de
la politique anti écologique des manuels
macron vous aviez promis son maintien
vous avez menti
résultat 25 mille camions plus sur les
routes par an et des emplois nécessaires
détruit pour planifier quoi pour
planifier le démantèlement de l'état
vous avez choisi pour ministre du
travail celle qui a réduit de 10% le
nombre d'agents aux services du
ministère de la transition écologique
pour planifier la poursuite du
glyphosate vous aviez promis de
l'interdire en 2021
il nous empoisonnera jusqu'en 2027 au
moins pour planifier la délocalisation à
tout va sur l'accord de libre échange
avec le mercosur
là encore flagrant délit de mensonge les
négociations ont continué et devrait
aboutir à l'automne pour planifier un
horizon vide de travailler plus pour
produire plus la misère progresse mais
vous subventionnez à coups de milliards
d'argent public
la distribution de dividendes aux
actionnaires et des licenciements par
milliers pour planifier la répression
des lanceurs d'alerté décrocheurs de
portraits des militants antinucléaires
de bure notre planification de la
bifurcation écologique et solidaire est
une méthode mais surtout un contenu au
service de l'intérêt général humain la
seule planification qui vaille doit
permettre à chacun de subvenir à ses
besoins essentiels
dans le respect des limites alors
monsieur le premier ministre votre
planification sera telle autre chose
qu'un combat contre le peuple
merci d'un panneau la parole et à madame
barbara pour piler ministre de la
transition écologique
merci monsieur le président madame
madame panneaux on se connaît bien on a
travaillé ensemble aussi au sein de la
commission développement durable et gens
vraiment hommage à tous mes collègues de
cette commission qui vont beaucoup me
manquer vous dit beaucoup de choses mais
ce que j'aimerais c'est que on essaye si
on veut avancer ensemble pour l'écologie
on a notre sensibilité vous en avez une
vous le savez j'en ai une et vous le
savez si on veut avancer ensemble
il faut qu'on essaye de sortir des
postures et il faut qu'on essaye de
regarder les choses froidement il y a eu
vous n'avez pas parlé du tout de ce qui
a été fait déjà vous n'avez pas parlé du
tout de ce qui a été fait la loi
mobilité
lannoy sur le climat de ce qui a été
fait également sur l'économie circulaire
de ski à et pourtant on n'y a participé
ensemble de ce qui a été fait pour la
transition énergétique et je peux vous
dire que je vais continuer donc essayons
de voir les choses et de voir là où on
nous devons effectivement nous améliorer
nous avons un rapport du haut conseil
pour le climat qui est sorti ce matin
et évidemment nous nous entretiendrons
avec eux qui nous dit qu'il faut
accélérer sa tombe bien je l'avais dit
aussi et ça tombe bien le gouvernement
le premier ministre le président de la
république le disent aussi donc
travaillons plutôt ensemble pour y
arriver on va avoir des chantiers sur le
plan de relance sur la manière
d'impliquer tout le monde sur la
stratégie nationale bas carbone mais
aussi sur la loi qui va arriver sur
l'application de ce qui a été préservé
pour la part donc si a été proposée sur
la convention citoyenne sur le climat ce
que nous on doit faire ce que des
collectivités doivent faire ce que les
entreprises doivent faire beau son
ensemble là dessus s'il vous plaît on
est attendu sur des résultats et mais ce
que l'on soit dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition
ces résultats ils seront au service de
nos concitoyens et donne
enfants et donc travaillons ensemble
pour y arriver je suis une mère de
famille je peux vous dire que ça
m'intéresse d'apporter un monde meilleur
à ceux qui nous suivent merci madame la
ministre la parole et à monsieur bruno
fuchs monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'inquiétude est extrême sur la
situation du député malien soumaïla
cissé arrivé second aux dernières
élections présidentielles
soumaïla cissé représente la voie
principale de l'opposition démocratique
au mali
ils étaient capturés dans une embuscade
le 25 mars dernier nous sommes sans
nouvelles depuis
mes chers collègues je veux lancer ici
en notre nom et un appel solennel à la
libération immédiate du député soumaïla
cissé
je formule également le souhait que la
france use de toute son influence pour
qu'il puisse poursuivre son engagement
politique le plus rapidement possible
monsieur le ministre rassure et nous
rassurer sa famille et ses proches
donnez-nous enfin de bonnes nouvelles
par ailleurs ce rapt nous rappelle
l'importance majeure de l'action de la
france au sahel
ils nous renvoient également aux enjeux
qui touchent à la stabilité et la
gouvernance de nombreux pays de l'espace
francophone en guinée conakry par
exemple alpha condé réfugié de longue
date et de longues années en france veut
comme d'autres avant lui changer la
constitution pour l'autoriser à un
troisième mandat
les chats collègues et vous surprendre
mais par un tour de passe-passe la
constitution ratifier par référendum
n'est pas celle qui a été publiée
officiellement
et je m'étends pas ici sur les
répressions meurtrières aveugle contre
les civils au gabon le sort réservé au
principal leader d'opposition jean ping
assigne à résidence doit nous alerter
dans le même temps le chef de l'état
n'est plus en capacité de présider son
pays depuis 18 mois en raison de son
état de santé
le gabon et la guinée mais aussi le
cameroun le bénin la guinée-bissau et
d'autres ont tous adhéré à la charte de
la francophonie et ont signé les accords
de cotonou et notamment son article 9
ils sont loin aujourd'hui d'honorer leur
signature monsieur le ministre le
président de la république parle d'un
nouveau chemin pour les deux prochaines
années à venir
comment la diplomatie française
va-t-elle dessiner un nouveau chemin
dans ses relations avec l'afrique
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur jean yves le drian ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le monsieur merci
monsieur le député bruno fuchs la france
avec vous mais ici dans cet hémicycle
dit son indignation devant la situation
faite à monsieur soumaïla cissé ces deux
leaders de l'opposition
il a été candidat aux élections
présidentielles il dit pris en otage
depuis trois mois et nous appelons
fortement à sa libération
nous appelons ceux qui l'enferment
aujourd'hui à le mettre à la disposition
de la démocratie malienne
par ailleurs vous avez évoqué la
situation au mali c'est vrai qu'il ya
aujourd'hui une période de tensions
sociopolitiques du un arrêt de la cour
constitutionnelle à la suite des
élections législatives du mois d'avril
qui rend la situation extrêmement tendue
et les présidents des états du sahel ont
exprimé dans le cadre de la cedeao la
conférence économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest
un certain nombre de propositions visant
à atténuer la crise et à faire en sorte
que le climat politique s'apaise
nous souhaitons que ces dispositions
initié par la communauté économique des
états d'afrique de l'ouest puissent être
mises en oeuvre par les autorités
maliennes actuelle et plus largement
monsieur le député en afrique et vous le
savez bien y compris dans les pays en
difficultés que vous avez évoqué notre
posture est de soutenir et la démocratie
et le droit la démocratie dans les états
fragiles
vous avez cité la guinée et nous
souhaitons que les initiatives soient
prises par le président condé pour
apaiser la situation
à la suite d'un référendum que nous
avons contesté mais c'est vrai aussi
dans les états en crise ou en
particulier au sahel mais aussi au
cameroun il ya des exactions qui sont
commises que nous n'acceptons pas nous
leur disons en permanence aux différents
chefs d'état merci monsieur le ministre
à paroles de monsieur patrick zèle
merci beaucoup monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
alors que la france n'est pas encore
sortie de la crise du couronne un virus
que tout le monde est d'accord pour
souhaiter un monde d'après différents du
monde d'avant on pourrait penser que la
reconstruction économique écologique et
solidaire annoncé officiellement par le
président de la république se traduirait
par de premières mesures destinées à
corriger ce qui semblait le plus évident
chacun aurait pu penser que les premiers
enseignements tirer de cette crise
serait bien évidemment prise en compte
et que la relance économique
l'amélioration de notre système de
chanter et la préservation de
l'environnement seraient les priorités
de votre nouveau gouvernement monsieur
le premier ministre
or le nouveau calendrier parlementaire
que vous venez de nous proposer révèle
que pour vous la priorité c'est le vote
en urgence c'est en catimini de la
seconde lecture du projet de loi
bioéthique et je tiens à insister le
tout en supprimant le vote solennel
initialement prévu on peut et on doit
tout d'abord s'interroger sur
l'opportunité de cette seconde lecture
dans l'hémicycle dans une telle
précipitation et ceci durant la session
extraordinaire
alors que la période estivale débute que
le pays vit sous l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qu'est le conditions ne sont
pas remplies pour un et un débat serein
et apaisé en cette période estivale
il serait pertinent de débattre de cette
question qui en appelle à l'intime et à
chacun d'entre nous ultérieurement
c'est d'autant plus légitime qu'en
septembre le sénat ne siègera pas et
qu'il n'y a donc aucune urgence à
vouloir passer un tel texte au forceps
en expédiant le débat cela ne serait
absolument pas respectueux ni de notre
assemblée ni nos concitoyens monsieur le
premier ministre dans un souci
d'apaisement de concorde et de l'union
nationale et conformément à vos propres
déclarations depuis votre nomination
accepteriez vous monsieur le premier
ministre d'aller dans ce sens afin
d'être effectivement un accord avec vos
propres déclarations
je vous remercie
la parole merci chers collègues la
parole à toi monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur le député patrick hetzel
appeler un chat un chat dit que vous
êtes contre la possibilité que nous
voulons donner aux couples de femmes aux
femmes seules de poires des enfants et
une famille
utiliser des arguments de fond monsieur
untel mais utiliser des arguments de
fond vous n'êtes plus crédible sur le
fond que sur la forme pourquoi monsieur
l ah bon parce que ce texte il a déjà
plus d'un an
c'est en catimini un peu long un an déjà
démarche parlementaire
ensuite parce que ce n'est que la
deuxième et dernière lecture
ensuite parce que la commission spéciale
de bioéthique a fait un formidable
travail et qu'elle a adoptées sans coup
férir le texte dans les délais qui
étaient impartis et parce qu'il ya des
attentes sociétales qui sont nombreuses
messieurs les députés je demanderai un
minima de remettre votre masque quand
vous criez pensez à votre groupe ne
criait pas un cluster dans l'assemblée
nationale
montrez l'exemple montre l'exemple seul
candidat jeudi est donc ce n'est pas une
loi adoptée en catimini
on est déjà un an de démarches les
parlementaires de tous bords ont
travaillé il ya d'ailleurs des questions
consensuel qui peuvent transcender les
clivages politiques
ce sont les avancées sociales davos et
sociétal qui sont importantes qui font
également je vais baisser d'un volume
vous baisserez peut-être le vôtre ce
sont des avancées également important
pour la médecine pour la recherche dans
notre pays ce sont des roches et des
données qui sont importantes pour les
enfants qui sont encore chers de
filiation que sont des questions qui
sont importe mais si mais si pour
combattre de nouvelles maladies et puis
pour ses belles avancées sociétales que
moi un titre de ministre des solidarités
la santé je prône déjà depuis un certain
nombre d'années que je suis très fier
que notre gouvernement portent à savoir
l'autorisation de considérer l'évolution
des familles comme une évolution
sociétale saine sereine normal le débat
va suivre son cours et je l'espère le
plus tôt possible
merci monsieur willy la parole est à
monsieur frédéric descrozaille dit
monsieur le président ma question vous
avez la parole je reconnais mais cette
fois la question s'adresse au ministre
l'action et des comptes publics me
glisse dans le contexte que nous
connaissons
si l'état n'était pas intervenu notre
économie sera un champ de ruines et
c'est reconnu par l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques le fait que l'action de
l'état a été efficace dans ce contexte
les urssaf accompagne des entreprises
leur propose des solutions et plus
particulièrement depuis la loi que nous
avons adoptée en août 2010 8 pour un
état au service d'une société de
confiance et je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur un point particulier
certains chefs d'entreprise ont besoin
et sollicite les urssaf pour transiger
en fait sur des dispositions prévues
dans le projet de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale adoptée le 22 décembre
2014 selon des dispositions
réglementaires précisé dans un décret
paru le 15 février 2016 des transactions
donc par exemple pour des pénalités de
retard
or les urssaf sont obligés de leur
opposer une fin de non recevoir
navré parce que ce fameux décret du 15
février 2016 prévoit que ces
transactions
ces transactions doivent être conformes
à un modèle de protocole transactionnel
défini par arrêté ministériel
arrêté ministériel qui n'existent pas
parce qu'il n'est jamais paru donc
monsieur le ministre soit dit en passant
que aucun agent de l'état ne se soit
sentie responsable du fait que la
volonté du législateur régulièrement
établis en 2014 n'est pas applicable en
2020 en raison d'une inconséquence
réglementaire voire administrative
ça laisse songeur pour le dire
aimablement donc ma question c'est
est-ce que vous nous confirmer que vous
allez prendre une disposition rapide
pour que cette situation soit
régularisée et que les chefs
d'entreprise puis solliciter les urssaf
pour ses fameuses transaction prévue
depuis 2014 et surtout que les
dispositions que nous allons adopter
dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificative dans l'examen va
recommencer aujourd'hui même vont bien
être établi avec le même esprit de
service qui anime les urssaf de la même
manière partout sur le territoire et
pour tous les chefs d'entreprise merci
monsieur le député la parole à monsieur
olivier du soft ministre chargé des
comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames
merci à tous mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député descrozaille à
questions précises réponse précise la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2015 prévoit effectivement
la possibilité pour les ursaff d'une
procédure transactionnel un décret a été
publié en février 2016 il manque un
arrêté avec le modèle de protocole
transactionnel s'est arrêté va être
publié dans les semaines qui viennent
pour que ces dispositions puissent être
mises en oeuvre
au-delà de cette réponse précise
j'espère satisfaisante
votre question me permet de saluer le
travail des urssaf le travail des urssaf
depuis plusieurs mois est absolument
exceptionnelles pour accompagner les
entreprises en difficulté ce sont les
urssaf qui sur instruction de mon
prédécesseur la mise l'action et des
comptes publics ont mises en oeuvre le
report des échéances de cotisation pour
permettre aux entreprises de toutes
tailles de bénéficier d'une trésorerie
particulièrement préservé pendant toute
cette période de crise ce sont aussi les
urssaf qui vont mettre en oeuvre
l'article 18 du projet de loi de
finances rectificative que vous examine
actuellement cet article 18 voulu à la
fois par gérald darmanin et par bruno le
maire permet l'exonération des
cotisations sociales dans de conditions
particulières d'abord pour les
entreprises de moins de dix salariés
les tpe qui ont fait l'objet d'une
fermeture administrative elles seront
exonérées de cotisations patronales pour
trois mois et nous avons prévu aussi de
leur accorder un crédit de cotisation
qui leur permettra de faire face aux
échéances à venir et nous allons élargir
cette exonération de cotisations aux
entreprises de moins de 250 salariés des
secteurs les plus frappés par cette
crise je pense notamment au secteur des
cafés hôtels restaurants mais aussi aux
entreprises qui sont particulièrement
lié à ces entreprises qui ont subi une
mise à zéro parfois de leur chiffre
d'affaires pendant cette activité
la meilleure démonstration je crois de
l'implication à venir des urssaf pour
garantir la mise en oeuvre des
dispositions du plfr c'est ce que les
urssaf ont fait pendant les trois
derniers mois le réactivité au service
des entreprises de france
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur jean paul dufrègne
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre il ya quelques jours
l'assemblée nationale a adopté dans le
cadre de notre niche parlementaire ce
que tout le monde appelle depuis
plusieurs années la loi chassaigne même
si votre majorité on a réduit la portée
avec un système d'écrêtement et une mise
en application à compter du 1er janvier
les députés communistes et gdr se sont
réjouis de cette avancée pour près de
200 mille retraités agricoles dans le
minimum retraite ne pourra plus être
inférieure à 85 % du smic contre 75%
aujourd'hui lors de nos discussions il a
été adopté un amendement précisant que
la date d'entrée en vigueur pouvait être
avancées si les solutions techniques le
permettait la mutualité sociale agricole
dit aujourd'hui que rien ne s'oppose à
ce que ce dispositif soit appliqué dès
le 1er janvier 2021 l'entendez vous des
directives seront elles donner
rapidement ce sens pour autant le
problème des conjoints n'est pas réglée
et toutes ces femmes aux 12 heures de
travail par jour est dit sans profession
vont continuer de percevoir des
retraites entre 300 et 500 euros par
mois ce n'est plus tolérable
ces femmes de l'ombre participait aux
travaux agricoles et levait les
volailles faisait les fromages qu'elle
vendait au marché local en plus de tenir
la maison
l'adoption de la proposition de loi
chassaigne a remis en lumière cette
situation pour les femmes de la
génération concernée
monsieur le premier ministre pendant
encore combien de temps celles qui ont
tant travaillé
oui tant travaillé vont-elles percevoir
des retraites de misère nous déposerons
prochainement une proposition de loi
pour y remédier
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député jean paul dufrègne je
le dis clairement il ne faut pas
attendre
on a beaucoup trop attendu depuis
beaucoup trop longtemps
donc comme on dit moi je remettrai pas à
demain ce qui peut être fait aujourd'hui
et ce qui éclaire aussi c'est que vous
connaissez la mobilisation et je
voudrais vraiment rendre hommage à mon
prédécesseur didier guillaume la
mobilisation du ministre la mobilisation
de cette majorité
mais la mobilisation de beaucoup d'entre
vous pour en finir avec cette injustice
du niveau de rémunération des
agriculteurs des agricultrices pendant
leurs activités ou après à la retraite
et je salue la ppl du président
chassaigne bien connu ici
cette proposition de loi et qui a été
débattue c'est une véritable avancée
sociale vous l'avait dit et moi je
l'assumé clairement et j'en ferai un axe
de mon action le social dans la veine de
l'agriculture c'est très important c'est
très important d'avoir une politique
sociale agricoles et une fois qu'on a
dit ça
vous savez pourquoi l'amendement a été
portée c'est à dire une amie une mise en
application plus tard en 22 mai deux
pouvant être avancée dès lors que le
système d'information permettra
permettra de s'assurer que l'ensemble
des droits fait avec la msa soit assurée
dès lors que le système sera prêt moi je
m'y engage
on mettra en oeuvre je ne remettrai pas
à demain ce qui peut être fait
aujourd'hui
s'agissant de la retraite des
agricultrices là aussi il faut agir avec
méthode
c'est intolérable vous l'avais dit je
partage il ya une mission qui a été
confiée au député lionel causse et
nicolas turquois que je salue dont les
travaux doivent être remis à l'automne
pour pouvoir avancer notamment sur ce
sujet évidemment il faut que ce soit
fait dans la concertation mais
évidemment là aussi il faut avancer vite
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame martin allez-y me suis tu
freines pardon
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre réponse
pour positive est effectivement notre
proposition est tout à fait dans le
prolongement de notre ppr et les deux
questions vous l'avez souligné sont
étroitement liés vous avez activé
accepter la première eh bien je suis
certain que vous ne refusez pas les
riches car ce serait la dystonie à
madame martine vos nerfs monsieur le
premier ministre à la santé mentale ne
peut plus être le parent pauvre de la
médecine
s'il est une chose que la crise
sanitaire nous est démontrée c'est la
grande fragilité d'un secteur qu'il est
urgent de réformer la détresse psychique
n'épargne personne
combien de patients de soignants
d'étudiants de parents et de personnes
isolées ont perdu pied pendant le
confinement mais aussi depuis le
déconfinement lépi phare a observé que
les anxiolytiques ont augmenté pendant
cette période de 290000 prescription de
même pour les hypnotiques avec 100000
prescription supplémentaires le nombre
de passages aux urgences home pour
motifs psychiatriques a quant à lui
triplé dès le début du déconfinement
qu'en est il des patients enfermé contre
leur gré au prétexte du confinement
sanitaire la contrôleur général des
lieux de privation de liberté dans son
dernier avis s'est indigné des
conditions d'hospitalisation de certains
patients
elle a relevé des atteintes graves aux
droits fondamentaux dans plusieurs
hôpitaux psychiatriques et a déclaré que
le secteur avait besoin d'une nouvelle
loi le conseil constitutionnel saisi par
une qpc a répondu le 19 juin en
demandant au législateur que les
pratiques d'isolement et de contention
puissent être soumises au contrôle d'un
juge
la loi doit changer et ce dès fin 2020
je rappelle que caroline fiat et moi
même avons fait état dans notre rapport
sur l'organisation de la santé mentale
de la situation très précaire de ce
secteur à bout de souffle
nous avions formulé des propositions
concrètes monsieur le premier ministre
ne vous trompez pas l'impact psychique
de cette crise sécuritaire
mérite de placer la santé mentale au
centre des préoccupations c'est en effet
un sujet majeur pour le groupe écologie
démocratie et c'est dans les solidarités
le ségur doit être plus que de simples
annonces budgétaires
c'est pourquoi je vous le demande êtes
vous prêt à accroître les financements
de la santé mentale et pouvez vous vous
engagez quant à la proposition d'une
nouvelle loi de solidarité et de la
santé madame la députée c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu pendant cette période de crise qu
vide une augmentation et on le comprend
des troubles anxieux parfois des
troubles dépressifs des familles qui ont
été confinés pendant des semaines chez
elles des personnes qui ont été éloignés
de leur emploi d'autres qui l'ont perdu
cet artisan qui ferme son commerce subit
lui aussi un stress très fort cet enfant
qui ne va pas à l'école et qui
s'interrogent pourquoi sur les raisons
pour lesquelles il est éloigné ses
copains subit aussi un stress qui n'est
pas allègre a négligé vous savez pendant
toute la période de crise qu vide et
notamment pendant la période de
confinement nous avons mis en place du
soutien psychologique pour toutes celles
et ceux qui en relever ou qu'il voulait
en émettre le souhait avec des appels
téléphoniques des numéros verts des
plateformes des associations des
psychiatres des psychologues
c'était indispensable il ya même eu est
d'ailleurs un soutien psychologique
important mis en place à destination des
soignants qui eux mêmes ont été soumis à
un stress qui justifiait pleinement
qu'on les accompagne
et puis y'a le secteur de psychiatrie et
des soins qu'ils soient en milieu ouvert
ou en milieu fermé ça a été très dur
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion dans cet
hémicycle de saluer le travail
extraordinaire extraordinaire des
soignants en milieu psychiatrique parce
que c'était encore plus difficile
c'était encore plus difficile de gérer
les 14 n de gérer les mesures
d'isolement d'expliquer à des malades
qui parfois peut évidemment comprendre
mais parfois ne peuvent pas appréhender
ce qui est en train de se passer
notamment des malades en situation de
délire et cet accompagnement du
quotidien avec l'éloignement plus des
familles des proches aidants était
encore plus dur et pourtant la
psychiatrie est tenu la psychiatrie est
tenu j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
l'ensemble des acteurs de la filière à
plusieurs reprises les saluts et de les
remercier et de tenir compte des
organisations qu'ils avaient su mettre
en place 2
dire ce que nous puissions dans la durée
nous appuyer sur leur initiative nous
travaillons pour cela avec franck
bellivier professeur de psychiatrie et
qui est déléguée interministérielle et
puis maintenant madame la députée nous
avons un travail qui a commencé un
travail de résilience collective la
crise n'est pas derrière nous le gros de
l'épidémie de cette vague épidémique est
derrière nous il nous faut nous
reconstruire individuellement
collectivement dans notre vie du
quotidien dans nos familles de nos
cercles amicaux et professionnels
évidemment il faut pour le faire bien
mouret merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'égalité femmes hommes de la
diversité et de l'égalité des chances
madame la ministre vous êtes le nouveau
visage de l'égalité femmes hommes
votre parcours est un sans-faute modèle
d'un ascenseur social qui honore la
république dans ce qu'elle a de meilleur
vous portez désormais la parole et les
intérêts de l'ensemble des femmes de
notre pays
initialement ou peut-être encore grande
cause du quinquina quinquennat nous le
savons plus pour autant qu'il soit
exemplaire et méritant le modèle ne fait
pas la politique
votre vision de la lutte pour l'égalité
nous sommes très libérale au regard des
déclarations que nous vous connaissons
or la sortie de la crise que nous venons
de traverser a démontré la réalité de la
condition de la majorité des femmes à
savoir être invisible sous payés et
surchargé la république c'est toujours
grandi apporter son soutien aux plus
fragiles et à leur permettre une
émancipation qui au passage ne passe pas
uniquement par le travail tel que le
prône le gouvernement c'est le cas pour
toutes celles qui ont été en première
ligne
à l'occasion de la crise sanitaire le
haut conseil pour l'égalité femmes
hommes s'accordent à dire que le risque
est grand que les inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes s'accroissent
maintenant les femmes sont la voie de la
pauvreté et de la dépendance
nous nous nous interrogeons sur votre
vision du féminisme alors qu'en 2018
vous déclariez mon conseil serait de
prendre davantage de responsabilités
plus vous montez dans la hiérarchie -
vous êtes confrontés au sexisme au delà
de la discussion autour de la machine à
café est ce le message que vous
souhaitez porter si les superlatifs
que jamais à ce quinquennat au delà de
la communication marque de fabrique du
président de la république
allez-vous renouer le lien avec les
associations féministes et entamer un
travail collectif avait les moyens pour
lutter contre les violences faites aux
femmes à la hauteur des anges merci
merci chers collègues la parole thomas
labellisé vêtement est nommée ministre
déléguée chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes de la diversité et
de l'égalité des chances
bonjour à tous bon jour à tout c'est un
véritable honneur pour moi d'être avec
vous dans cette salle aujourd'hui j'ai
l'habitude de vous regarder à la
télévision et être ici avec vous ça me
paraît totalement surnaturel vous n'êtes
plus beau en vrai
[Rires]
madame la députée merci beaucoup pour
votre question c'est une question qui me
touche personnellement
pour plusieurs raisons comme vous le
savez tous je ne suis pas une femme
politique et je n'avais jamais envisagé
de rentrer dans la politique
jusqu'à ce que monsieur le premier
ministre m'expliquer pourquoi c'était le
moment de le faire et il y a des
engagements qui ne viennent pas du
cerveau mais qui viennent du coeur
inutile de vous dire que parce que je
suis une femme parce que je suis une
mère parce que j'ai grandi dans une cité
quand je vous dis que l'émancipation
économique est la base pour sortir de la
misère et de la pauvreté et pour être
considéré c'est une vérité
maintenant il ya un autre élément parce
que j'ai appris que je n'avais que deux
minutes il y à un autre élément que je
voudrais souligner et il a été évoqué
par une députée qui viennent d'envoyer
un message qui est pardon j'ai oublié
son nom mais elle me dit je suis dans
l'éducation
je ne serais pas ici devant vous
aujourd'hui si je n'avais pas eu la
chance d'avoir des enseignants qui m'ont
appris à parler à marcher à me déplacer
et à m'exprimer
alors oui l'émancipation économique est
fondamentale mais elle ne peut avoir
lieu que si tous les citoyens et
citoyennes sont formés qu'ils ont une
bonne éducation et qu'ils peuvent lever
la tête et avancer
et je terminerai en vous disant que je
n'aurais pas quitté mon emploi que je
n'aurais pas quitté l'afrique du sud où
mon mari et ma fille se trouvent encore
pour venir vous rejoindre aujourd'hui si
monsieur le premier ministre et madame
et monsieur le président de la
république c'est vraiment deux minutes
dans ce petit blog là j'ai terminé mon
kiff auteurs s'ils ne m'avaient pas
garanti que cette cause de l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes restaient
et resterait encore une grande cause du
canal si madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur thierry benoit
merci mon cher président monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre au nom des députés du groupe
eut d y est indépendante je voudrais
saluer votre nomination ainsi que celle
des nouveaux membres du gouvernement de
ce gouvernement et dire ici que je
souhaite naturellement pour la france et
les français
la réussite de votre gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre je voudrais
aborder un point qui m'est chère qui
nous tient à coeur mais ce stade un
sujet très sensible
c'est la question du cumul de
l'encadrement du cumul monsieur le
premier ministre
des rémunérations des fonctions d'un
certain nombre de hauts fonctionnaires
nous avons travaillé dans cet hémicycle
dans notre pays
nous avons clarifié ce sujet du cumul
pour les élus locaux pour les
parlementaires et pour les ministres
tant en termes de fonctions qu'en termes
de rémunération sur le premier ministre
nous sommes en 2020 et les français
comme moi apprennent qu'un haut
fonctionnaire peut cumuler certaines
fonctions dans le cadre de son métier il
est délégué interministériel présidé une
agence de l'état
il peut aussi cumuler ses fonctions avec
des mandats d'élus locaux et lorsqu'on
fait le cumul de la somme des fonctions
de la somme des rémunérations et des
indemnités
certains montants choquent un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes
ils ont été nombreux à nous le dire à
l'automne 2010 8 au mouvement au moment
des mouvements sociaux qui avait
concentré un certain nombre de français
sur les ronds points
monsieur le premier ministre je voudrais
vous interroger pour savoir si vous
inscrivez votre action dans la volonté
du président emmanuel macron et dans la
volonté traduite par edouard philippe
au début de cette législature d'apporter
de la clarification encadrement fonction
rémunérations indemnités pour un certain
nombre de hauts fonctionnaires je vous
remercie
merci la parole à madame amélie de
montchalin ministre de la transformation
de la fonction publique
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le député vous pouvez compter
sur l'engagement plein et entier de ce
gouvernement pour garantir l'exemplarité
et la transparence vote bpl en janvier
2018 a permis au gouvernement de prendre
des engagements
ils ont été suivis par la publication
d'un décret vous le savez en février
dernier notamment un décret qui permet
pour les autorités administratives
indépendantes d'avoir une seule règle
pour fixer les rémunérations nous
avançons également sur la transparence
de la queue d'un rémunérations des hauts
fonctionnaires et vous pouvez compter
sur moi un point important à mes yeux
nous devons attirer les meilleurs nous
devons rendre notre action publique plus
proche plus efficace plus simple nous
devons évaluer ceux qui sont aux
commandes de notre action publique et
tous les agents doivent pouvoir non pas
être dans la suspicion mais être dans
l'action et donc compter sur ce
gouvernement si nous voulons les
résultats si nous voulons que sur tous
nos territoires les français est une
action publique à leur service si nous
voulons que les agents puissent être
soutenu leur combat quotidien de rendre
service et nous l'avons vu ils ont tenu
pendant la crise nous devons avoir la
transparence avoir de la clarté avoir
des règles nous allons les clarifier si
besoin
mais comptez sur nous pour mener le bon
combat le bon combat c'est servir les
français
c'est leur apporter là où ils sont une
action publique qui correspondent à
leurs besoins et à leurs attentes à la
modernité du 21e siècle et doute pouvons
sur ces sujets ne prendre aucun retard
je tiens ici et c'est le sujet que vous
abordez les hauts fonctionnaires
d'autres pays ont permis à l'état de
tenir
nous devons les accompagner les évaluer
et c'est ainsi que nous travaillerons
par la confiance parce que les français
attendent des résultats et nous devons
toujours soutenir ceux qui leur
apportent
si madame la ministre la parole à
monsieur adrien cnas monsieur le premier
ministre c'est un parlement une nouvelle
fois abaissé qui se réunit aujourd'hui
mis à la disposition du gouvernement à
sa convenance
dans une séance de questions
exceptionnelle alors que votre discours
de politique générale n'aura lieu que la
semaine prochaine
par conséquent nous ne savons pas qui
dans cette assemblée vous accorde sa
confiance ou ne vous la corde pas mais
il est vrai que la cour n'a pas besoin
de vous entendre pour vous applaudir dès
lors que le monarque que vous a choisi
nous savons que parmi vos intentions
figure celle de remettre à l'ordre du
jour la réforme des retraites que 70%
des français rejeté et contre laquelle
nous avons mené une rude bataille
parlementaire soldée par un lamentable
49 3
soyez assuré monsieur le premier
ministre que vos intentions ne saurait
passer inaperçu et que nous sommes
disposés s'il le fallait à vous menez
une bataille plus rude encore que celle
que ce parlement a connu il y a quelques
mois
en effet nous avons eu l'occasion de
démontrer mille fois ici que derrière
les bonnes intentions affichées se casse
un projet qui ne vise qu à contraindre
les français à travailler toujours plus
longtemps pour atteindre le même niveau
de pension et quand cela il est
contraire aux engagements présidentiels
il prépare une rupture certaine avec le
modèle solidaire par répartition aux
bénéfices des assureurs et des banques
alors notre pays subit le choc d'une
récession brutale
certains doivent se faire tout petit sur
ses bancs qui nous expliquait qu'avec la
même proportion de richesse nationale
consacrée aux retraites
on pourrait servir toujours plus de
retraités par ailleurs monsieur le
premier ministre
alors que plus de 700 mille jeunes
entreront sur le marché du travail à la
rentrée
dans ce contexte de chômage accru
l'avenir n'est pas à travailler
davantage
mais bien à travailler moins pour
travailler mieux et travailler tous pour
obtenir le plein emploi
à mesure que la productivité a augmenté
ce combat est le fil rouge du mouvement
ouvrier dans l'histoire et nous n'y
renoncerons jamais monsieur le premier
ministre
alors que les syndicats vous disent non
et que l'opposition parlementaire vous
dis non
pourquoi vous entêter dans cette
déclaration de guerre sociale au br si
chers collègues la parole tabac
labellisés
born et les u travail de l'emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député 4 mince je connais
votre engagement sur les questions
sociales et pour ma part j'aurai à coeur
de travailler avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires comme des partenaires
sociaux pour apporter des réponses
concrètes à nos concitoyens
alors vous le savez notre pays traverse
une crise sans précédent et je pense que
cette situation inédite devrait nous
conduire à sortir des postures et des
caricatures est ce que vous le savez
monsieur le député tout autant que vous
j'ai à coeur de conforter notre
protection sociale
et c'est pourquoi le président de la
république et premiers ministres ont
exprimé leur volonté de s'appuyer sur
l'ensemble des acteurs de la démocratie
sociale pour surmonter la crise d'
aborder l'ensemble des sujets et de
bâtir un système de protection juste et
équitable adaptée aux enjeux du 21e
siècle
parce que ce système de retraite que
vous défendez avec tant de vigueur
monsieur le député est il juste il ne
l'est pas et vous le savez il est
injuste pour les plus fragiles de nos
concitoyens il est injuste pour les
femmes dont les pensions sont
inférieures de 40% à celle des hommes
il est plus adapté à la réalité des
parcours professionnels
voilà pourquoi nous devons en
responsabilité engager une concertation
pour plus de justice sociale avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et je serai donc
aux côtés du premier ministre pour
engager ce dialogue dès demain la tâche
devant nous est immense et les bases
sont solides
la méthode est posée la volonté est là
et je sais qu'elle est largement partagé
sur ses bancs merci madame la ministre
la parole est à mme adam g l
banier merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse au ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais vous alerter
sur la situation extrêmement
préoccupante dans laquelle se trouve la
pédopsychiatrie dans le département de
la mayenne avec une succession de
fermeture de centres
médico-psychologiques à château gontier
et renée évron faute de médecin à la fin
du confinement il a été annoncé que le
cmp de château gontier resterait fermée
provisoirement
il est proposé à 40 des 120 patients a
suivi à laval mais sept à trente
kilomètres et à 40 km de routes
si les cmp dernier et d'évron ont pu
partiellement rouvrir ils sont en
réalité en sursis de plus les cmp de
mayenne et laval sont également menacés
puisque des départs de médecins sont à
prévoir
les familles les élus s'inquiètent
logiquement pour la santé des enfants et
l'absence d'alternative de soins un
collectif s'est créé non seulement pour
soutenir les médecins mais aussi pour se
préoccuper de la réponse qui sera
apportée pour des enfants en grande
souffrance psychique le maintien d'un
service public de proximité et de
qualité est indispensable dans
l'ensemble des territoires
un enfant suivie depuis six ans au cmp
de château gontier nous le rappelle j'ai
des troubles autistiques
et quand je suis au cmp je réussis à me
calmer et puis il ya d'autres enfants
comme moi et même d'autres pour qui
aller au cmp est indispensable bref s'il
vous plaît ne fermait pas le cmp
monsieur le ministre
devant cette crise sans précédent dans
notre département dynamique dans la
qualité de vie n'est plus à démontrer on
l'a vu avec l'énumération des festivals
dans la mayenne de madame bachelot tout
à l'heure mais troisième désert médical
de france
quelles réponses pouvez vous apporter
aux patients et à leurs familles en
attente de continuité des soins
merci chers collègues la porte à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé
madame la députée géraldine banier au
delà de la situation particulière de la
mayenne que vous dans votre question
vous faites en fait en réalité état
d'une situation problématique dans notre
pays tout entier le problème c'est celui
de l'accès aux soins notamment en
pédopsychiatrie sur une partie
croissante du territoire national c'est
inacceptable
vous demandez si je compte fermer un cmp
je n'ai jamais eu l'ambition la vocation
la volonté l'idée saugrenue de fermer
assembé en revanche effectivement il
faut des médecins des soignants pour
ouvrir un centre médico psychologique
comme il en faut pour ouvrir des
hôpitaux
je veux que la france mette le paquet
pour la filière de pédopsychiatrie nous
ne pouvons pas rester les bras ballants
a constaté que des enfants qui se
trouvent qui souffrent de troubles
doivent attendre 18 mois pour avoir un
diagnostic doivent attendre des semaines
ou des mois pour pouvoir bénéficier de
soins spécialisés ou de rééducation
c'est un drame du quotidien pour les
enfants concernés
parents concernés pour les enseignants
concernés et je crois qu'un pays comme
la france devrait s'enorgueillir de
mettre encore une fois le pack l accent
est tous les moyens tous les moyens je
le dis avec sincérité mêmes émotions
pour pouvoir structurer une filière
digne de ce nom en matière de santé
mentale et d'accompagnement de l'enfant
nous pouvons envisager différentes
solutions madame la députée je ne peux
pas faire ici de propositions qui ne
serait ce qu il serait arbitre m il ya
des idées créé peut être identifiée
demain une filière spécifique de
pédopsychiatrie à côté de la filière
psychiatrique adulte je ne sais pas je
leur parlais avec les experts peut-être
rendre faciliter l'accès direct aux
psychologues sur prescription pour les
mineurs peut-être que la france est
capable de faire cela aujourd'hui compte
tenu de la situation et pour vous
répondre sur le cas précis du cmp que
vous citez je crois qu'il ya une bonne
piste
avec le recrutement d'un médecin en
provenance du chu d'angers qui viendrait
à partir de septembre
faire une vacation et de madère au cmp
de château gontier ce serait un
doublement par rapport à l'existant et
puis il ya des postes partagés entre le
sésame et le ch la balle pardon je dois
ici et m'y remets fiche je ne connais
pas encore tous les établissements de
france en tout cas madame la députée
merci pour votre sollicitation votre
attention pour cette grande cause
des quelques récents pas plus que
quelques secondes simplement pour faire
un appel aussi aux étudiants en médecine
il faut venir aussi dans nos territoires
qui ont besoin de médecins merci la
parole à madame josiane corps de l'eau
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
je souhaite vous alerter sur la
catastrophe économique et financière qui
risque de décimer une profession entière
si rien n'est fait en effet seuls les
discothèques font encore à ce jour
l'objet d'une fermeture administrative
contrairement aux cafés restaurants qui
ont pu reprendre leurs activités à
partir du 2 juin sous réserve d'observer
strictement des gestes barrières
j'ai reçu les gérants des discothèques
de ma circonscription qui m'indique une
réouverture le 21 septembre comme
semblent le prévoir le gouvernement
entraînera le dépôt de bilan de 90 % des
établissements installés en saône et
loire
à l'échelle du pays ce sont 1600
discothèque et 120 mille emplois directs
qui sont menacés si l'autorisation de
rouvrir ne leur est pas accordée dans
les plus brefs délais j'ai bien
conscience que le virus est toujours là
mais que constate-t-on avec la fermeture
prolongée des discothèques le contraire
de l'effet recherché avec la tenue de
fêtes clandestines organisé à partir de
sites dédiés comme soirée privée sur le
net ou bien par le biais des réseaux
sociaux
ce sont ainsi des milliers de jeunes qui
se réunissent lors de fêtes improvisées
dans lesquels aucune mesure de
protection sanitaire n'est respectée les
gérants de ces établissements sont des
professionnels responsables parfaitement
à même d'organiser des fêtes dans le
strict respect des gestes barrières
continuer de leur interdire de reprendre
leurs activités revient à les traiter en
coupable et a condamné la plupart
d'entre eux à disparaître du paysage
économique et de notre patrimoine
culturel populaire et festif c'est
pourquoi monsieur le ministre je vous
presse d'écouter l'appel au secours de
ces hommes et femmes qui ne méritent pas
l'ostracisme actuelle que leur oppose
deux gouvernements
aucune entreprise ne peut survivre à
sept mois de fermeture
il y a urgence monsieur le premier
ministre quelle solution allez vous
proposer un service dont la seule chance
est de pouvoir retravailler merci
ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame la députée josiane corneloup vous
venez de recevoir des applaudissements
fournis de tous les bancs de cette
assemblée nationale et pour cause la
seule le seul élément j'enlèverai votre
question c'est le mot ostracisme de la
part du gouvernement
c'est inutile et c'est factuellement
faux vous avez raison madame la députée
de rappeler que les discothèques sont
fermées pour raisons sanitaires
elles ont été parfois ouvertes dans
certains pays parfois refermer la suisse
la semaine dernière enregistré un cas
dans une discothèque qui a conduit je
crois confinement de 300 personnes du
jour au lendemain avec des risques de
diffusion communautaire c'était le gars
aux états unis ni l'allemagne ni henry
en place des règles assez strictes
puisque je crois que de la danse il est
autorisé en position assise l'italie a
autorisé des groupes indépendants les
uns des autres à danser lorsqu'ils
étaient arrivés ensemble ou issus de la
même famille vous comprenez bien que
chaque pays essaye de faire comme il
peut la france a pris la décision de ne
pas rouvrir la discothèque en l'état
compte tenu de la situation sanitaire et
des risques ce n'est pas la faute des
acteurs du monde de la nuit
ce n'est pas non plus la faute de
personne qui danse et qui font la fête
et on peut parfaitement le comprendre
ce n'est là c'est la faute à un virus
c'est la faute à un virus qui circule et
des conditions qui permettent au virus
de se transmettre et de mettre en danger
tout le plan de levée du confinement qui
a été réussie mis en oeuvre par le
premier ministre alors qu'il était pas
encore premier ministre madame la
députée il faut accompagner les acteurs
du monde de la nuit et nous voulons
accompagner les acteurs du monde de la
nuit personne ne peut survivre à la
fermeture d'une activité économique
pendant sept mois vous avez raison mais
le gouvernement l'avez vous remarqué
madame la députée n'a laissé mourir
personne de son activité économique
depuis le début de la crise ni les
salariés avec 12 millions salariés au
chômage partiel ni les artisans ni
indépendant ni les commerçants qui
pointent après mois ont perçu des aides
et c'est tout à fait normal et l'etat
sera au rendez vous pour venir en aide
aux acteurs du monde de la nuit je ne
veux pas répondre à la place du ministre
de l'économie et des finances et de la
relance mais sachez que j'avais demandé
la semaine dernière à ce que les
représentants de la filière soit reçue à
mon ministère
alors empiétera celle ce qui était alors
secrétaire d'état nous n'abandonnons pas
les acteurs du monde de la nuit et j'ai
conscience
j'ai conscience des fêtes clandestines
j'ai conscience des bars qui ne jouent
pas le jeu
il faut qu'ils aient du contrôle merci
messieurs fini la séance des questions
au gouvernement est terminée prochaine
séance cet après midi à 15 heures suite
du projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2020 la séance est
levée